[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
hey you guys today is charles whitman
it's
yeah it's friday look he's got his flock
of cigal shirt on finally
i bought him that a long time ago and
it's like i bought you that for
christmas right yeah i bought you that
for christmas it warned a couple times
and he's only worn it a couple of times
yeah i totally forgot you had it you
hadn't worn it for so long
to go looking like i know you're [ __ ]
with me stop wearing that goddamn shirt
at least you're wearing a shirt with a
handsome man on the front
well i like that he's like you know i'm
looking like super serious and pissed
off this way i'm looking super seriously
pissed off this way they got five of me
on that shirt
[ __ ] to go there's only four of them
not five
no there's like there's one one two
three three four
i thought there's a piece of one okay
all right
tom can't count you heard
for now says hey i got the same shirt on
as jenny yeah it's like this one
i i kind of feel like this is one that i
made it's like a little bit crooked
it's hard to like fit things over my
boobs because my boobs are also crooked
they are one's bigger than the other
okay well it's just like most people's
like boobs most
feet like one's bigger they can't tell
but you can't you can't tell though
i can tell yeah it's because they're
yours
i have to look at the stupid things all
the time you know what i mean
they're just right there i can't even
look at my feet without seeing them uh
zach says hey y'all jenny and i tried
that thing you said about having kilt
with ice in it
what i don't know with ice in it and it
was amazingly refreshing what's a kilt
with ice in it i don't know
uh yeah was that an autocorrect yeah
happenstance there because i'm like
wait probably milk yeah milk with ice in
it i don't know
it doesn't matter move on who the [ __ ]
puts ice in their kilt system
yeah your balls would freeze instantly
yeah that's maybe it was milk with ice
in it which i must have mentioned on
some show at some point because i really
like milk with ice yeah
but yeah uh how do i join for 20 a month
for merch and help you guys out just go
to our patreon
page and become a patron
or you alternate alternately
you can go to paypal because i have a
paypal account
and uh it's actually just under my name
which is jenny ashford or
my email address which i'll give you if
you uh message me
and you might be able to do like a
rolling
because i mean like an automatic pay
because i do that on
on um what is it [ __ ] welcome to the
basement
they have a paypal and like i give them
like five dollars
we just have to make sure that we will
remember him
on shirt day yeah well i would you would
because i always check
uh i always check check patreon as well
because remember we used to have that um
that young lady uh that gave us 20 a
month on patreon like pretty regularly
so i was like got her a shirt too okay
so you know you mean paypal you need
paypal paypal yeah
yeah you know what i mean but uh yeah
yeah
yes i did mean milk with ice in it yeah
yeah um
honestly i put ice in everything because
it's florida and it's hot as balls and
you can't really
i don't really like to drink anything
that's room temperature or even like
refrigerator temperature everything has
to be like arctic
temperature otherwise i'm not down with
it
you know yeah so i'm just saying uh
speaking of patreon
i think i forgot to mention one of our
patrons sydney
actually increased their actually
doubled their support like this past
week and i meant to mention on a
wednesday and i think i forgot because
we um got into the whole manly man
discussion and then we were just like
drinking that show was a disaster
it was yeah but it was a beautiful
disaster
but like i said that's why we have a
sidetrack show so that we can just like
get drunk and like be like wow it didn't
have anything talking about
it didn't have anything to do with that
subject we went off
we got sidetracked off of that one
because you know what i mean but
we can't even keep to one [ __ ] yeah
we're terrible
how i couldn't really keep on that
subject
and and uh there wasn't a lot of
audience [ __ ]
interaction about it so we just [ __ ]
[ __ ] just went on
i know uh juan says happy friday time
and jen how are you both we're pretty
good
thank you very much it is friday i'm a
little bit sleepy but i think i'm gonna
be okay which maybe i mean
we're kind of thinking about going out
after the show i think we should
so i mean just a mannequins which isn't
far we're not like going all the way to
downtown orlando or anything
yeah but we'll see how it goes we'll see
how it goes i'll just i'll get some
i i have some uh iced coffee so i felt
like
after the after the booze i was like
won't you give me some iced coffee and
give me some caffeine that'll like wake
me up
esther said uh the show the wednesday
show was great i suggested the topic and
we'll take the heat wasn't so much the
topic i thought was gonna be a good
topic it's just it's hard to stay it's
hard it was hard to stay on that topic
well it's hard for us to stay on any
topic well it's hard for you to stay on
a new topic let's
let's say that okay well just you know
what i meant to get
i don't know it's just i just gotta get
in the mood and [ __ ] go down that
groove you know what i mean that's what
i mean well and
i think that's what a lot of people like
about the show um like i said if you
know you guys have been with us forever
it's like every now and then i still get
a comment like hey i came here to hear
about
x whatever the topic was um and you guys
went on about a bunch of different stuff
i'm like oh you must be new here
yeah um but you know it's just kind of
like
we eventually get around to like talking
about the topic but
you know sometimes it might take a while
but people need to like just relax
just relax you know what i mean yeah you
don't have anywhere to go
that's what i mean it's just good let's
[ __ ] right
you wouldn't be listening to to a
youtube show
to a four-hour fight yeah you can you
know there's you can go on wikipedia and
look at some [ __ ]
because honestly like if i'm gonna like
the only time like if i'll listen to
like a four-hour
show about something i usually have that
going on in the background like while
i'm working on stuff like while i'm
working on like graphic design or
whatever
so driving and yeah so it's like i like
having somebody's voice in the
background like it's either scary
stories or it's like really really
long yeah like podcasts are just really
really long like i said i like jade the
libra because i just like her voice and
she's just going out shopping for
halloween decorations
yeah and she'll do like an hour or two
with doing that and it's just kind of
like i don't know
there's just something really nice about
that uh
oracle said the side tracks are so much
fun yeah we have a fun time doing those
too
i think that's kind of like that's
probably my the thing i look forward to
the most because
they're easy they're easy it's like i
don't have to do any research it's like
if [ __ ] goes off the rails it doesn't
really matter
because you know what i mean we're just
doing that for we'll keep
on yeah yeah so it's super fun
but yeah so there we go um yeah should i
go
but you know i'm sitting there there you
know it's supposed to be you know what
makes a manly man
it's difficult to say but definitely soy
the
soy boys are not manly you know what i
mean there's a lot of that going on and
the sedentary lifestyle of a lot of
millennials sitting down in offices
that can do an office work all day
[ __ ] long
you're not gonna produce much [ __ ]
testosterone doing that
because it takes physical activity to do
it so you're just gonna
not go through puberty properly i mean
some of these guys look like they don't
go through puberty
i'm looking at the dude he's like 25 he
looks like about 14.
you know well what are you going to do
like i said i'm not i'm not judging
right people just well i'm kind of
judging you you live the way you want to
live you will live
i don't think they chose that they were
forced into that by the by the job
market
well i mean there's not really a lot of
i mean nobody's out there like
[ __ ] and they're building railroads
yeah they also don't know
they also don't really know any better
because that's they're all kind of
growing up like that a lot of them
forestry down says testosterone and wigs
make a manly man
and then dj maniac said i live a
cemetery lifestyle right same
um so yeah uh fox obsidian the fourth
says i really like the side tracking it
gives me more of you guys to listen to
while at work making the day better so
yeah you see thank you uh karen says the
show was kind of conceived
based upon radio shows anyway well yeah
like i said it's kind of more of like a
hangout and sometimes you know we have a
topic that we're kind of like
orbiting around but you know karen says
jenny i got my daughter that overlook
shirt
she loves it so do i i love that shirt
too there's so many like good shining
shirts
i'm just gonna have to like get [ __ ]
you know
[Laughter]
camp guys said i'm embarrassed to be off
topic so much i just haven't seen a lot
of the movies that's
that's fair i mean you know there's a
million movies i still need to see too
even though i've seen a lot but they're
still i still have a big huge
ever growing list of [ __ ] yeah so
this show i'm sorry to say this show is
kind of a bummer
yeah um it's really weird because i was
looking earlier
um you know i'm doing like research
about the show and everything and i
usually try to
watch like a you know a panoply of
different uh
documentaries about [ __ ] there's really
not a lot of documentaries about this
guy
it was a long time ago there was well
yeah but it's like that doesn't
that doesn't really matter there's a
zillion documentaries about jack the
ripper and that was like more than 100
but i don't know i always thought this
was a really interesting case like i
kind of felt like it popped up in like
pop culture
a lot in the 60s and 70s but then i
don't i don't think it necessarily got
forgotten about
but it's one that doesn't really get
brought up all that much when they're
talking about
mass murders or mass shootings even
though
i don't know i always found it really
interesting like i said we we talked
about it a little bit because we did
that
uh movie the deadly tower with kurt
russell in it where kurt russell was
playing
great movie was playing charles whitman
yeah so we talked a little bit about the
real case then but i kind of wanted to
dive more into it
um and it's funny because we just did we
just rewatched um
full metal jacket too and there's like
also a reference to child
charles whitman in there being a marine
and that's where they taught him to be a
sharpshooter
although i will say that that's not
entirely accurate because actually his
dad taught him to shoot
and he was like really really good at
shooting before he went into the marines
so it wasn't necessarily the marines
that taught him a lot of a lot of those
guys were though
yeah that was common if you go to the
guys that volunteer for the marines back
then the same kind of guys that
volunteered for the army interest
army infantry now a lot of them grew up
shooting especially the ones that add up
in rangers
yeah so at least during my time i don't
know what it's like now
but um yeah in case you guys don't know
who whitman is
i think everybody knows probably who's
whitman is he's a guy that went up and
went up on top of this pickle tall tower
and started shooting people
yeah pretty much at random the texas
tower well yeah at random
texas tower sniper well no it's not
pretty much at random i mean
it was we're not totally at random he
was he was aiming at a university wasn't
he
and then he'd go down and shoot at some
cars and then he'd go back
no he didn't do that no okay i thought
he did no he stayed up in the tower the
whole time
um he actually no i mean i know he
stayed at the tower
i'm saying he i thought he was shooting
at a campus
most of the time well he had gone there
prior yeah and then he would shoot at
some cars
if i remember correctly oh i don't know
if he shot at any cars he was mostly
shot and
shooting at people okay um you know it's
just it's a
it's a [ __ ] up i thought he shot at
some car story but maybe maybe uh yeah
oracle's saying
that um that she lives in austin and
they still talk about it here which
obviously that's where it happened so
you know um thank you victor
i'm two degrees separated from today's
topic my high school principal was on
campus that day i can't even imagine
how [ __ ] horrifying that must have
been um
i watched actually if you go on youtube
and you search for charles whitman or
search for texas tower sniper
there's actually like a news special
that came out back then like in 1966
and it's like a half hour like 25
minutes or something like that
and i guess it came out like the same
day or the day after that the [ __ ]
actually happened
and it's just really interesting like
seeing the news from like 1966 and they
were kind of cutting back to like
interviewing people that had like
you know gone in there like while the
while he was still shooting to like drag
dead bodies out of the way and stuff
like that
and it was just like it was some crazy
[ __ ] but that was kind of like the only
i don't know like i said there weren't
really a lot of i think there was a
little bit about him on that show most
evil but it was just kind of like a you
know like an eight-minute
segment um it's really weird how they
didn't really
even though i think he's like
fascinating from a psychological
standpoint i think he's like a
fascinating
character you know uh yeah i don't i
don't i don't really think so
i didn't i thought whatever
i don't think he was that fascinating
okay what he did was a [ __ ] trip but
he i don't think he was very special
well no i didn't mean that i didn't mean
special i just meant it was interesting
because of the whole tumor situation
because or maybe you know we'll yeah
we'll get into that like
like i said i think that's kind of like
something it was just a natural disaster
a guy had a [ __ ] tumor
guy had a brain tumor he wasn't it he
wasn't thinking right
yeah david jean said it's not a tumor
yeah it's not a way
it's not a tumor what does that mean you
never saw that movie with arnold
schwarzenegger uh no
what [ __ ] movie was that was it was
it kindergarten college i think it was
kindergarten
i never saw that one yeah yeah he just
uh had a damn brain tumor he thought his
mom was trying to kill him he thought
everybody was after him
he didn't think his mom was trying to
kill him i thought he said his mom was
trying to kill him no did he write
didn't he write something about her in
his
yeah but it wasn't it wasn't that okay
he was crazy
well i know that but it's like normal
yeah he didn't um
he didn't he actually loved his mom and
uh
he wrote extensively he because he wrote
like a lot of suicide notes and he left
like a lot of stuff
uh you know explaining what he had done
um
but he never said anything about his mom
okay
he hated his he hated his dad he didn't
kill his dad though
all right he wasn't acting right he he
wasn't
you know i don't think he was totally
responsible for what happened i think it
was a natural disaster
he had a brain tumor yeah and you know
and i mean obviously they don't know if
that had something to do with it but
i don't know it might have it might have
pretty sure
i mean he really did he had some um he
knew there was something wrong with him
he did uh there were some warning signs
prior
uh to it you know like a few years prior
like he would say some weird [ __ ] or
like act weird or whatever
um and he had like some [ __ ] from his
childhood and whatnot so it's kind of
like it's hard to say but i do think
that was probably like a contributing
factor for sure
guarantee you if that tumor wasn't there
that [ __ ] wouldn't happen probably not
probably not um it was that was might
have been
like a contributing factor but that was
probably the
contributing factor yeah the one that
actually made it happen
yeah because uh you got something wrong
with your [ __ ] brain
yeah i could have swore he was kind of
having hallucinations though
i don't think it was hallucinations um i
thought those letters were kind of
[ __ ] discombobulated didn't have
anything no what was really happening no
they weren't
all right the sad thing i'm confused
with somebody yeah i think you might but
because the thing about the letters is
that that no they're coherent
the saddest thing about them is that he
really really seemed to know that there
was something the matter with him and he
couldn't figure out what it was
yeah um but that came across in the
letters that he's like i don't know like
why i'm thinking these things i don't
know you know what i mean he would say
things like that so he knew something
they're the same guy
he knew something was the matter with
him i don't think he was like
hallucinating or anything and he didn't
like
think his mom was going to kill him or
nothing like that um but
it's kind of like obviously it's way
sadder for
his mom he did yeah yeah okay but not
for the reason that you think
well at least according to what he said
he killed his wife too yeah
um yeah victor said my principal said
people shot back at whitman from the
ground yeah they did
um a lot of people did yeah they did um
well because the cops it took them right
a little while to get
up there because he had like blocked all
the stairs off and he was like
he had like seven firearms and he had
like taken up a whole bunch of
supplies because so he was gonna like
hang out for a while
you know what i mean what was his last
stand yeah
pretty much it's just like it's so
bizarre it's it's bizarre
because what happened that day
and then like reading the letters that
he left it almost doesn't
it almost doesn't track it almost
doesn't seem like the same person
yeah because he seemed very aware that
what he was doing was like really bad
and like really wrong but he was just
like gonna do it anyway yeah it's the
same guy
yeah i remember somebody narrating what
he was writing and it it's
it's not it's not coherent from the
point of view
of a sane person you know i mean doing
it for a motive
the motive was all [ __ ] up he didn't
know what he was talking about
it was kind of like a he was delusional
yeah but like i said he seemed aware of
that but it was like really
like [ __ ] him up yeah that's the way
head injuries are when yeah when you
have stuff like that
they're looking through reality through
a very distorted prison they think
they're right about something but then
they know something's wrong with that
it's just you know what i mean it's not
a moral problem it's an organic problem
with how the brain processes things
yeah you know i mean uh uh
now i i understand and i was i remember
hearing it going yeah
[ __ ] he's got [ __ ] brain problems
you know yeah i mean [ __ ] i have [ __ ]
multiple head injuries
i know i kind of know how it is but not
to that extent
you know uh yeah but um
and usually like the most dangerous time
for head injuries is like that first two
years
so i guarantee you that that thing had
been growing in there for a long time
they said it was about the size of a
pecan that's pretty big
that's big for a breeze yeah yeah so it
was growing in there putting pressure on
his head and [ __ ] [ __ ] up in there
and uh who knows what the biochemistry
looked like you know
you probably had all kinds of weird
antibodies and reactions and [ __ ] going
on inside the brain trying to
fight that thing off that's
mind-altering
yeah imagine like lsd but worse
you know what i mean more realistic it's
like that
yeah but yeah it's pretty [ __ ] up yeah
so you know
he wasn't insane i don't really blame
them no i mean
yeah it's like i don't you know i know
that's kind of like a weird thing to say
but it's like i really do think
in this case it was probably like 95
biological um so like you said it was
almost kind of like
and i'm not like natural disaster yeah
or like an act of god almost if you want
to call it that because it's kind of
like
i mean i'm sure that doesn't make the
victims families feel any better because
you're just like walking around the
campus or delivering newspapers or
whatever you're doing and some
[ __ ] shoots you that's not the
way the life is though but
you know what i mean life isn't about
who's right and wrong and casting blame
and [ __ ]
i mean you can do that if you want to
feel high and mighty but then they got
women who get postpartum depression and
drown all three babies in the damn tub
all right it doesn't make people feel
better that [ __ ] well she had this
postpartum depression but they don't go
to prison
a lot of times you know what i mean
that's a known thing
yeah well you could put a [ __ ] brain
tumor in a guy's brain it's about like
that
yeah i mean like i said so magenta
pigeon says do you guys believe it was
genetic or his own doing i think it was
largely
that tuna probably largely that tumor
yeah i mean he did have
like i said he did have some uh warning
signs even from his childhood
that a lot of other mass shooters mass
murder type people have
but i don't think if he hadn't had that
tumor i
may be probably 95 sure that he would
not have done what he did depends on how
big that tumor is and where its location
is yeah and a lot of other factors that
happens
like for instance she just said that he
had a lot of stuff in common with
shooters other mass shooters there's
millions of dudes like that and they
don't actually do it well yeah i know
that's what i'm saying
millions of millions there are millions
of dudes that have a lot of the traits
of a serial sex offender
or a serial killer and they've never
they'll never commit a crime
but they have those same traits you know
but they don't actually ever do it you
know
so trying to piece together for forensic
stuff you know
well you know he was one of these and
that
you get down to the organic [ __ ]
get down to the organic situation and
the the biggest [ __ ]
the biggest second clue to this whole
thing is that damn brain tumor
guarantee if that brand timber wasn't
there that [ __ ] wouldn't happen
probably yeah well that's what i'm
saying it's very very likely that it
wouldn't have
i don't think he would have done what he
did um
you know like i said not excusing it
that's not cool or anything like that
but it's just kind of like i
definitely think this was more like a
tragedy yeah
um some people say well it's a easy
access to guns [ __ ] that [ __ ]
would be the kind of guy
if you take the guns away next thing
he's running people over with trucks
and then they've actually have a better
kill ratio with those trucks
recently a truck is those fully
automatic trucks
that [ __ ] in the right place at the
right time going down the right sidewalk
will get a lot more than guns
i mean they got dudes that just go down
the subway and just wait for train go by
and push
people into the damn way the train it's
another one that's going on right now
if if you're [ __ ] a lunatic
and you want to kill some people there's
all kinds of ways
you'll figure it out and they do yeah
oracle said uh he also had a history of
being physically abused by his dad yeah
he did
i have to wonder if there was an old
injury that got exacerbated and
triggered the tumor growth yeah that
could be
uh possible but uh yeah like i said it's
it's kind of hard to say because it
really does seem like reading
his letters is really sad
because like i said he really did seem
to know that something was wrong
he really did try to he seemed like he
was trying to get help
but it that i mean i'm not saying nobody
helped him like he did go to like
psychiatrists and stuff because he was
like complaining
about you know these intense headaches
and all these weird thoughts that he was
having
um but i just think maybe nobody took it
entirely seriously or they didn't like
didn't x-ray his head yeah and that's
what i mean they didn't really like
look into it with you know as much as
they should have unfortunately and
you know a lot of people ended up dying
because of that
but again hindsight is 20 20. a lot of
these guys that have that type of
that type of [ __ ] brain problems and
head injuries and stuff
can be very high functioning they can
pass a lot of [ __ ] tests and exams
they know exactly what's going on but
they just kind of can get kind of warped
you know and go down a path of thinking
that they can't come back from
you know i can yeah after after my
[ __ ] head injury
i would [ __ ] fight at the drop of a
hat but i was also extremely
[ __ ] romantic i was getting [ __ ]
lots of girlfriends and [ __ ]
because you don't have a filter yeah you
see a beautiful woman used to approach
her
and you got all kinds of confidence you
know
it works you could be you know you could
be a sweetheart and [ __ ] and then some
dude says something sideways next thing
you know you're on the ground fighting
and [ __ ] [ __ ] they're trying to lock
you up
you know it lapses though
yeah imagine if you had an ongoing
tumor that's growing in there
yeah it never gets better it just gets
worse and worse i can imagine it
yeah especially if it was in a bad spot
like up near the frontal lobes where
you're right that's where your process
is
and inhibition where your individuals
are inhibitions are yeah
[ __ ] right yeah not a good situation
not a good situation all around yeah
that's why the punisher if you
that his secret power is his [ __ ]
head injury that's why he's
he's got his damn [ __ ] skull [ __ ]
x-ray on the front of his armor
because you can go into it you can go
into the rage
and the same kind of rage that
these dudes on [ __ ] angel dust are
pcp running through streams of [ __ ]
nine millimeter rounds and just
pure adrenaline so yeah
there's something to it well yeah i mean
your brain
yeah that's kind of an important organ
yeah that's kind of like your whole
personality
so something gets [ __ ] up in there
well the mind can become [ __ ] like
totally [ __ ] um just totally jacked
up
and immune to pain and you can keep your
blood pressure way high even though
you've lost a lot of blood
um you don't get tired
superhuman chimpanzee tile strength
eventually it catches up with you though
it's like pcp
like angel dust you know they're doing
that same kind of thing
yep eating some eating people's faces
eating people's faces although we don't
know what that dude was on
maybe that dude just wanted to eat
somebody's face i don't really know
you see daredevil season two when the
punisher shows up
john bernthal i think his name john
bertholf bernthaly bernthal yeah
his portrayal of a [ __ ] tbi traumatic
brain injury [ __ ] veteran that's spot
on that's it
that's it yeah yeah well yeah
yeah he did his research well i mean you
know because like most of you guys know
like tom had an uh
head injury also yeah uh back in 94
on 94. back in 1994. and that's you're
like that for a couple years
yeah yeah it's just
it's it's really really interesting but
it's also like kind of scary
yeah because it just seems like you know
it would just take one
accident or like one oh i fell and like
hit my head on the side of the bathtub
and then all of a sudden you're like a
totally
different person but it has happened
what's worse is multiple head injuries
when there's
several of them over over a course of
time like on a foot like a professional
football player
they can get even worse yep yeah
well yeah we did didn't we do like
something i think we talked about that
case because we watched that netflix
documentary about that dude that was
like a football player
yeah and he ended up killing his wife
and yeah
well i think he one of them was a
football player the other one was a
wrestler and those guys also take
steroids which keeps the swelling down
so they they could have a head injury
and not know it
because it never really swelled up that
bad
you know chris benoit that's right
christmas
so what happened to him was also
steroids the steroids prevented him from
knowing that he had a serious head
injury
that's how they treat a head injury but
you don't go out and get other head
injuries
on top of that oh boy let's go another
head
that dude [ __ ] eventually just blew
up
i mean i'll try to keep my brain you
know
pretty much intact i don't really want
to get hit in the head with a
they erase that dude from wrestling
history uh which
i feel sorry for him because that didn't
could not
control his actions he his job was to be
hit in the head over and over again with
damn metal chairs
but i mean and i mean in this day and
age they should know that that's not a
[ __ ] great idea well it wasn't this
day and age that was [ __ ] back in
there was the 80s i think
late 80s early 90s and that wasn't him
that did you know that yeah dj maniac
they said his brain looked like an 85
year old all-time location authenticity
yeah
that wasn't him man she was just
multiple head injuries that's just like
i mean you would think you would think
that that would be common sense
those dudes kind of didn't have common
sense they would clearly they
came from nothing and they were making a
[ __ ] ton of money and they were big
superstars and they were [ __ ] yeah
they hit me with that clown hand yeah
keep hitting me yeah you know they were
having fun
yeah and i'm sure there will be no
terrible side effects of this
whatsoever this will not affect anyone
in my family
you know i'm just saying yeah it seems
like
like i said your brain that's kind of
like that's kind of the most important
thing in your body kind of
um so you know we're getting off topic
but in that era those guys
just did not have the knowledge it was
all
pre-internet so people couldn't compare
notes you couldn't have access to
doctors
yeah uh you couldn't find out what
multiple head injuries would do what
steroids would do to you
what can what all that [ __ ] would do to
you [ __ ] over time
and you know or condensed into a small
area
of time you know what i mean they didn't
really know they were kind of the
pioneers
of that [ __ ] and uh no you
you now i can get yourself killed you
can kill other people
yeah that's what i'm saying if it's just
you i don't think anybody would really
give that much of a [ __ ] but it's like
yeah that wrestler guy i don't [ __ ]
blame him that's another that's another
[ __ ] um natural disaster that wasn't
him that was that that was those head
injuries that did that
he didn't mean that mr robato says tom
if a head injury caused the problem a
head injury can solve the problem
that's true and then i was gonna say
just like in the cartoons and then dj
maniacs
because remember like in the cartoons
and i feel like in a lot of old sitcoms
like there was always one plot line
where somebody would hit their head and
get amnesia and they would forget
everything
and the solution for that was always you
had to hit them on the head again and
then their memory would magically return
which is uh not how it works in case you
didn't know
but yeah i just feel like that was a
trope in like so many not just cartoons
i feel like that was a trope in like a
lot of
uh like comedy shows and stuff like that
so all right so let's talk about uh
charles whitman let's talk about his uh
childhood so he's born in 1941
uh in lake worth florida he's a florida
man you guys
sorry uh lake worth florida is actually
kind of far from here
it's about almost three hours it's like
way down near south florida like near
fort lauderdale
so uh so he was like the oldest he had
two younger brothers
now his mom's name was margaret and his
dad's name was also
uh was also charles charles adolphus or
they called him ca
now just like
i kind of feel like there was this was
kind of i don't know you'd want to say
if it was like endemic to the era
but there was a lot of domestic violence
uh going on in this marriage
uh the dad ca would beat up on margaret
uh a lot he had his own business i
believe it was plumbing
uh he was a plumbing contractor or
something like that and um
he was kind of like one of those dudes
he's very very authoritarian
um he's very much everybody has to do
everything completely perfectly all the
time
or i'm gonna beat you so you had to
so he was like very much into like when
his sons were growing up
he was just like very you have to like
do everything right like you have to be
like super high achieving if you're not
i'm just gonna like
beat the [ __ ] out of you until you
straighten up he was that type of dude
and like i said i feel like there was a
lot of
those types of dudes um at that time
period that seems like a pretty wide
spread
so um so yeah so so he wasn't you know
real great like he used to beat the wife
up as well um you know emotional abuse
physical abuse all that kind of stuff
now when william was a kid
he was actually uh very intelligent they
gave him an iq test
uh when he was six years old uh and he
had a iq of 139
uh he was also they said as a kid he was
actually
a very well be well behaved he was like
really really quiet very polite
he was always you know just kind of
always very high achieving all that
uh kind of thing and um he basically
i think like he learned to play the
piano um you know he just
did all that he was like you know just a
normal like all-around kid and he was
like
really really intelligent and it just
seemed like a lot of his um
teachers also noted like how smart he
was
now uh his dad ca
uh you know he collected guns also and
like i said he taught all of the boys to
to shoot and uh maintain their weapons
and they went hunting together all the
time
um and at this point even when charles
was a kid uh they said he was actually a
he was an expert marksman like from the
time that he was a child so
like i said just you know because we
were making the joke about full metal
jacket where he was saying it's like
where
where did charles women learn to shoot
in the marines but he actually was a
good marksman before that
his dad taught him and he just seemed to
have a natural proclivity for it
i guess it's like shooting hoops yeah
when you get good with you understand it
and [ __ ] you can get good
you know yeah we grew up doing that his
dad even said about him this was a quote
from his dad said charlie could plug the
eye out of a squirrel by the time he was
16.
no yeah so he was yeah i learned at 10.
yeah so i mean he started learning when
he was like really little too but like i
said he had two younger ones remington
nylon 66. i don't know you guys might
remember what that is
it was it was a remington 22 long rifle
a semi-auto rifle a tubular magazine in
the butt you could put i think 15 or 16
in there it's fun had a little white
diamond on it
every kid had that and it was like a bb
gun it felt like a bit of plastic
kind of like an m16 yeah yeah and
you could get them for like 40 bucks 30
bucks in the 70s they were just
everywhere i remember those i think i
was seers
yeah yeah yeah i remember those i
remember like my cousins or something
yeah
i eventually could snap shoot me and a
guy named todd graves ended up being an
army champion shooter
and went to went to the same range that
his dad owned and he he was a [ __ ]
master
trick shot for the us army todd graves
you can look him up
he was a few years older than me but
we'll be standing out there at the range
i'd have that nylon 66 we'd throw
[ __ ] bottle caps up the air and try
to
snap shoot the [ __ ] bottle caps out
of the air with [ __ ] 22s
the trick is in the throw if you're
consistently throwing in the same spot
you're throwing it in the front of the
muzzle
just you just eventually you could hit
you know
50 out of 60 throws you know and then
you try to tighten it up
it's called snap shoot yeah anyway
david i was laughing because david june
said uh
said we were talking about amnesia uh
gilligan is known for getting amnesia
due to a coconut yeah i remember that
episode
and then dj maniac said uh and the
professor could make a radio out of
coconut but he couldn't patch a [ __ ]
hole in a boat
yeah there's really that's kind of taken
down the whole premise of the show right
there that he just couldn't yeah you
know
gilligan's island was an excuse to see
[ __ ] those dudes chase ginger and
marianne
come on that's what it was he had two
very different hotties and [ __ ] boat
everybody was gonna see who's gonna hit
[Laughter]
that's what i thought it was about even
from a young kid
well that's kind of the only thing
people remember from it nowadays
and like the professor like building
crazy [ __ ] but not being able to fix the
boat yeah
that's that's pretty uh yeah common all
right so
uh so charles uh joined the boy scouts
when he was 11. and he actually became
at that time what was the youngest eagle
scout i think he was only a little over
12 years old
when he made eagle scout and uh as i
said he also
by the time he was 12 was like a really
really good uh piano player
he was a pianist and he started doing
like a newspaper route like a lot of
kids did at that time
now he goes to high school in west palm
beach like i said this is south florida
um at the school he's like he didn't he
uh his teachers like recognized he was
like really really smart he was actually
like fairly popular
um you know just kind of a regular guy
and he actually ended up saving up a
bunch of money from his newspaper route
and actually bought a harley davidson
and that's what he used to do the
newspaper route because he's going
around on his
hog i guess so
after he graduated from high school in
1959
he actually joined the marines without
telling his
dad um you know
so he's he said or according to
i guess he had talked to somebody else
in their family like a relative or
something and had said that this is why
i joined the marines and didn't tell my
dad about it
because apparently about a month before
he joined the marines
um his dad had beaten the [ __ ] out of
him
and thrown him into the swimming pool
because i guess charles had come home
drunk and uh his dad was mad about it
so he beat the [ __ ] out of him and threw
him in the pool and charles was like
[ __ ] this i'm out of here
so he basically he went and joined the
marines
he um went on an 18-month tour
of duty uh this and he went to
guantanamo bay
uh at this point his dad still didn't
know about it
uh his dad actually didn't find out
about it until he was going to
paris island which like i said that's
again full metal jacket we're getting
back to that again that's where they
were
um well not really that's not where they
shot it but that's what they were
supposed to be
uh at this point his dad found out about
it and calls up
like the government and says hey can you
make my son like not be in the marine
style
but it's like you know what i mean it's
like that he was already like 18 at that
point so there's nothing that his dad
could do about it
but his dad tried to like get him out so
i don't know if he wanted to like wail
on him some more i guess i don't know
it's [ __ ] up
so uh during this 18-month
uh service which is 1959 1960 he
actually got a sharpshooters badge this
is like so
[ __ ] up like considering what happened
later on but yeah he got a sharp
shooters badge
and he also got the marine corps
expeditionary
medal um so
one of his specialties again this is
[ __ ] up knowing what happened
later was that he was really super good
at shooting rapidly over long distances
and shooting at moving targets those
were his like specialties i guess
so now at this point uh he wanted to
he applied for a scholarship like the
navy and marine corps scholarship
um because he wanted to finish college
out and he wanted to be
a commissioned officer now
when he took the test he got like really
really high scores
and so the selection committee said you
know yeah you know
you need to go into they sent him to
this prep school in maryland
and then he ended up taking this class
like math physics stuff like that and
then he got approved to
transfer to austin to the university of
texas
which like i said that's where the
shooting ended up happening spoiler
alert
he was going to study mechanical
engineering
so he goes to the university of texas
at austin in september of 1961
and he goes into the mechanical
engineering program now
excuse me when he first gets there um
he's really not doing all that well like
he was kind of like a shitty student at
first
but he had like i said he seemed like a
normal dude he had like a lot of like a
regular social life he had like a lot of
um hobbies he liked to go scuba diving
he did karate
he went hunting however he was also a
real big
gambler and that was something that
would get him in trouble
later on um so
not too long after he enrolled
at the university of texas him and two
of his buddies
were out hunting and they were poaching
they actually poached a deer they
brought the deer
back to charles's dorm
and they were like dressing the deer
like in the shower
of the room and i'm just kind of like i
can't even imagine oh that makes sense
how'd they even get it up the [ __ ]
stairs you know whatever like that
no i know but i'm just saying i was just
like everybody must have been like what
the
[ __ ] i mean it's texas maybe they didn't
really care yeah
but uh but yeah so since they were
poaching i guess it was out of season or
whatever
that's the deal so um so somebody saw
them
and like reported that poach it yeah and
uh serious yet
yes so they so he actually got uh fined
he got arrested and fined
um he got fined a hundred dollars which
today
today would be about 900 yeah still
lenient back then
yeah mississippi was tough on poaching
yeah oh yeah you're gonna do jail time
yeah but yeah so he got in trouble for
doing that but like i said
in hindsight uh not really that big a
deal
um now he was kind of known like i said
he was pretty social
and he was kind of like a practical
joker type dude
but even years before
the incident which he would come to be
known for
some friends of his actually did say
that he would say
some weird [ __ ] sometimes like
in 1962 a friend of his
said that while they were like hanging
out together charles like looked up at
the
tower that he would eventually like
shoot all those people from
and basically said hey somebody could
stand up
there and hold an army off like before
they
could get to you yep so he was like
maybe even thinking about it like
that long before it happened i disagree
that's not what's happening he noticed
that that was a good that was a good
defensive position
or an offensive position you could shoot
down he was already military at that
time right
yeah he just saw that and go man that's
an impregnable [ __ ] position right
there
later on when he went [ __ ] crazy he
said
where's a good impregnable position and
he remembered and he remembered that's
what happened he's not he's not
pre-planning it
he's just doing what a soldier would do
sorry i'm laughing at dj maniac stop
being vulgar it's pronounced it's pretty
pronounced pianoist instead of pianist
because every time you say pianist
yeah somebody thinks you're saying penis
but that's okay i
actually did say penis that time no he
had military training he just noticed
that that was a good position
well i guess in hindsight it sounded
like a creepy
yeah no and his friend was like oh man
that was [ __ ] up that he was saying
that like him four years before that
[ __ ] happened like
he had noticed it you just kind of do
that thing when you when you have kind
of
a military background you just kind of
see that [ __ ] instinctively
you know without even really thinking
about it
yeah because it's kind of beating into
you at such an early age he just
mentioned to that guy boy you got up
there man they couldn't get you out of
there
and then later and it turned out he was
right about that yeah
later turned out when he went nuts he's
like oh i'm gonna go to that place
remember that place yeah i'm going to go
there
yeah that's what he's doing that's
[ __ ] up yeah that's [ __ ] up
this just this this whole story just
makes me so sad like i was just i don't
know i was just like reading it today
and i was like watching the old like
news [ __ ] from 1966 i'm like man this is
a bummer
yeah see
i see some of these [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] going on today you know
because there's
there's a lot of [ __ ] brewing here in
the united states
and the past few decades the united
states has been in a couple [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] forever wars one in
iraq and one in
afghanistan and because it wasn't really
a real war it was more kind of like a
law enforcement mission
they changed all that training to close
combat
type stuff body armor room clearing
armored
armored personnel carriers they're kind
of doing what
what swat teams or police would do and
because of that
you have all these weird [ __ ] i don't
know if you want to call them protesters
or militia or [ __ ] whatever
civil unrest going on they're emulating
what they've seen
on television or on youtube of all this
combat footage in
iraq and their in afghanistan
they're wearing all that damn gear and
that weaponry and they're trying to
adopt all these tactics that are kind of
leaning towards close combat
but if you come from the old army which
was the
the [ __ ] apocalypse army world war
three the last you know the last thing
you ever want is [ __ ] close combat
all right it's got the highest casualty
rates it's the least effective
what you really want is far ambush and
that's what whitman's doing here
you would call this far ambush sniping
round for round man for men that's far
more effective
it's just funny how certain things go in
and out of style
so whitman's kind of using the combat
styles that he was trained with in the
marines so that was what was in style
then he came from a [ __ ] world war
three based army also or military
the marines at that time and he's just
he's just doing
what's best in his mind tactically it's
just funny how
it changes the way these mass shootings
look
you know now you got these jackals just
running into some
up on a crowd of people and just
shooting them up uh maybe get three or
four of them
then he gets killed whitman was up there
for a long time
though well hour and a half that was a
long time for a mass shooting and that's
because the tactics that he was using
and he wounded a lot of people he
wounded 31 and he ended up killing
16. right i just laugh at this [ __ ]
these dudes talking about civil war and
crap they don't
have any idea what they're talking about
no no i have no idea
if they're gonna be some kind of civil
war it's not gonna be the tactics i'm
seeing them use
they're gonna get [ __ ] killed they're
gonna lay them out
you know what i mean people just see
things on they just see
things on youtube and see what other
dudes
did in some [ __ ] [ __ ] war and
they think that's how it's done
it's gonna be a rude awakening well
nothing ever goes the way you think that
goes yeah you're watching someone else
do
yeah they're watching other people doing
it on another circumstance in another
country
thinking that that's how that shit's
done that's not how it's done
and it's always different it's way
different like watching when you're
doing anyway somebody else is doing it
and you doing it yep like i said that's
the story of my life
yeah so i mean it's good it's good that
you can watch other people doing things
like you can't learn things that way but
until you do it yourself it's not
right you're it's not and you know well
people are indoctrinated by video games
and all kinds of [ __ ] war never
changes like in the beginning
this video goes what the [ __ ] you
talking about i guess you're not i guess
you're not reading any history books
no two wars have ever been the same we
mean war never changes
they've never been each one's never been
the same they're each one of them is
different it's always just a situation
it has to do a lot of it has to do with
the terrain and politics because it's
always political
okay go ahead okay so get another drink
are you okay on yours well maybe like
fill it up a little bit okay
like i said i might need some coffee
before the end if we're actually gonna
go out before this but we're only at an
hour so it's fine
all right so early 1962 uh charles
whitman who was then 20 years old
he actually ended up meeting the young
woman that would eventually become his
wife her name was kathleen francis
lysner now she was actually an education
major she was 18
years old now i kind of feel like this
is something that happened a lot back in
this era but
they i guess he'd kind of had
girlfriends or whatever in high school
but nothing's super serious
she was like his first serious
girlfriend they go out for five months
and then they get engaged
so like i said nowadays people would be
horrified but like back then that was
pretty common
so yeah so they got engaged uh uh july
19th of 1962
and got married of august in that year
that's another thing that's crazy holy
crap that wasn't even like a month
from when they announced their
engagement to the wedding holy crap
nowadays i feel like people get engaged
and then like we're gonna get married
like two years from now i need like a
year and a half to like plan a wedding
holy crap
okay so it was like different back then
so so they got married at a catholic
ceremony like i said uh charles
whitman's family was catholic i don't
know if uh kathleen's were
as well the shitty thing about this
considering what happened later
was that kathleen's family thought he
was the bee's knees man
they just thought she had made such a
good choice
of man um you know they said oh he was
so handsome he's like really smart
um you know he'd been in the military he
actually had aspirations like doing
something in the future
and so he seemed to have he seemed to
check all the boxes
you know just goes to show you can't
ever tell
so now as i mentioned
when he started going to the university
of texas on the
you know the engineering thing that he
was doing he was on like a military like
a navy marine corps scholarship
now to maintain the scholarship you have
to have
good grades now he did really shitty the
first semester
uh the second and third semesters he did
a little bit better
but it still wasn't good enough so the
marines like
informed him they're like uh hey bro you
are not we're not going to pay for your
school anymore because you're not doing
as well as you should be doing
so in february of 1963 he actually got
ordered onto active duty
and he gets sent to north carolina camp
lejeune i guess is how you pronounce it
uh and that was he was gonna spend the
rest of his five-year enlistment uh
there instead of going to college
because like i said he wasn't
doing well enough to maintain the
scholarship money
now i guess charles was kind of
uh mad about this that he'd been i don't
he wasn't necessarily kicked out of
college they just said the marines just
said they weren't paying for it anymore
because he wasn't keeping his grades up
um now when he got sent to camp lejeune
though
he actually got promoted like to lance
corporal
now he even like did some heroic [ __ ]
right around this time there was um an
incident like there was an
accident where there uh was another
marine and they were in a jeep and it
like rolled
like into a ditch and he actually like
single-handedly like pulled the jeep off
the dude and like pulled the dude out
and actually like charles had to be
hospitalized for that
so you know so you know he was doing
some heroic [ __ ] like i said
now he had a repute like a good
reputation in the marines
um you know they said he was he was an
awesome dude but
as i mentioned earlier one of his
hobbies and this is bad when one of your
hobbies is gambling
uh he really really seemed to get into
a lot of debt and
it was kind of caused him a lot of
problems so in november of 1963
he got court-martialed
uh mainly for gambling also there were a
couple other charges usury
uh which i don't even know if they do
that for to anybody anymore like
would they court-martial you for usury
nowadays i don't know um
possession of a personal firearm on base
and also because either he had borrowed
thirty dollars
from another marine or another marine
had borrowed 30 from him and they got
into like this big fight about it
so that was another thing that was like
added to the list
um i guess they i guess the other one
barred them from him because he wanted
interest and they got into a fight about
it
so he got court-martialed he got
sentenced to 30 days
confinement 90 days of hard labor and he
got demoted
uh back from lance corporal to private
and like i said he couldn't he wasn't
going to college anymore either because
he wasn't keeping his grades up enough
to
sustain the scholarship now
during this time this is about 1963
uh when he was in the process of being
court-martialed
he started writing in a diary uh now his
diary was called the daily record
of cj whitman and
some of it it's pretty mundane [ __ ] he
would just write about what he was doing
in the marines he would write about you
know his
wife and he would write about his family
and stuff like that
um but he also read a lot of [ __ ] about
how mad he was at the marines for not
paying for a scholarship anymore
for court-martialing him um you know for
various other things
now the interesting thing though is that
he wrote quite a lot
about his wife um but
most of it like as far as i know like
all of it was like very very positive
like he was just always like she's the
most awesome person ever i wish like i
miss her so much and you know all this
other kind of stuff
so he never like seemed to i don't think
i ever
saw anything where he wrote anything
like derogatory about her or
that he hated her resented her or
anything like that it was mostly
you know the anger seemed to be against
the marine corps against you know the
kind of the bigger i guess governmental
or
societal system [ __ ] him over right it
was the more that i wanted to say
something about
wanted to address something uh midwest
outlaw 420 is
saying that he he's mentioning how i was
saying that
um there aren't many mass shootings like
whitman all right ones where they're
kind of doing a far ambush type type
sniping
with the exception of that las vegas
shooting mass shooting
didn't that dc sniper do that uh that
was
that was how many years i remember which
one dc sniper was anyway
2009 i can't remember now it's funny you
say that
midwest outlaw because if you look at
that las vegas situation
there's no way there's no way that was a
just a [ __ ] lone gunner mass shooting
right there that's got the fingerprints
of a [ __ ] foreign intelligence
operation
all over it that was
that was from another country like just
he had too many damn fighting positions
up there he had whole [ __ ] crates of
the same [ __ ] ar-15
over and over again as if he was waiting
for the rest of the team to show up
he had [ __ ] cameras and all kinds of
security
now he was waiting for a team of guys to
show up to help him
help him do that and when they didn't
show because the cops were on to him
they
the cops caught him early the mission
got aborted
he he [ __ ] the team didn't show and
he uh initiated fire
and then uh went down fighting he wasn't
alone
and that was something a foreign country
paid for
all right that's it's just that's just
not the work of one man
camp guy said instead of a fake
pregnancy appliance they should make all
prospective teen mothers take care of a
real three-year-old for a day or two
i always kind of felt like i mean when i
was growing up you know and
i don't know if they still do this
nowadays but they would do that thing
where you had to like take care of an
egg
for like two weeks or whatever and it's
like if it got broken like you'd fail
and so you had to like pretend like it
was your kid they were trying to like
teach you
you know responsibility it's like to
look after something like that
geriatric punk [ __ ] called out saudis
i was thinking the same thing
go ahead jenny but yeah so i don't know
if they do that anymore but i definitely
do
think i don't know maybe they should
have a class where you have to hang out
with like a bunch of children
i see i i never really like wanted
children or wanted to have children
young because
one i have three younger siblings who
are lovely um they actually weren't
brats or anything
but my i also have like a [ __ ] ton of
cousins who are all younger
and my parents ran a daycare for a
very large portion of my childhood so
i was like pretty familiar with being
around children all the time
and so i was like pretty adamant that i
really
it wasn't for me you know what i mean
because it was something that i grew up
around i'm like
yeah i don't think so but uh you know so
i knew it was going on but all right so
um
so yeah so like i said he also seemed to
be really resentful toward his father
which like i said not surprising because
his father was kind of an abusive
a-hole and uh you know had beat the crap
out of him and beat the crap out of his
mom and his brothers and everything like
that
so he kind of uh said some [ __ ] about
him as well
now december 1964 uh charles
gets honorably discharged from the
marines and goes back
to uh the university of texas and at
this point
uh you know he doesn't have a
scholarship anymore obviously uh and he
goes into
the architectural engineering program
but he also had to get a job to support
his family now he worked as a bill
collector
a bank teller a traffic surveyor like
those
types of jobs he also did
he was a scout leader that was a
volunteer job now his wife also worked
she was a biology teacher actually at
linear high school
so you know they were kind of having the
regular you know
mid 60s middle class type of
lifestyle now at this stage
um charles whitman apparently
admitted to his friends that on a couple
of occasions
that he had actually hit his wife
and this caused him a great deal
of anguish because he knew
that he was becoming like his father and
that was kind of like his worst
nightmare bet you that was that tumor
growing in there
it might have been yep it might have
been uh yeah so yeah because this was
only this was only a couple years
like a year or two of prior losing the
ability to keep us cool
he's losing his [ __ ] what do you call
it his uh inhibitions
yeah he's getting more aggressive and
mad and a frontal head injury will
[ __ ] make you
angry fly off the handle yeah that's
what's happening there
and then he's blaming himself because he
doesn't at least when i had a [ __ ]
when least when i had my head injury i
knew what it was
yeah and i had [ __ ] you know i mean
guys at walter reed going this is what's
going to happen to you man it's going to
you're going to be like this
yeah you got like warned i had a right
you're warned ahead of time yeah
but he didn't have that he didn't have
all that so he's blaming himself
and i bet you his personality over those
last few years started to be built
around the symptoms of that damn
tumor it probably did so he kind of got
twisted around that
not knowing that that was an alien force
happening in there
i could imagine he began to suspect it
later right um
because he really did i mean he was a
very intelligent
man so he really did seem aware
that something was wrong that his
perceptions get skewed
right that well well that he that the
thoughts that he was having were
i don't think that he said anything oh
they were coming from like an alien
like intelligence but he knew that they
weren't normal
that it was something from not that he
wouldn't have been thinking otherwise
so he really did seem aware of that and
even though he did
beat up on his wife he would always be
like really he's like i really don't
want to be like this you know it's this
is what my dad was like and i always
didn't want to be like my dad and so he
got like really
despondent because he felt like he was
turning into his father and like he
couldn't control it
because he hated his father it was just
that tumor getting bigger
yeah it's like really shitty because
they said even like in his journal and
stuff he was talking about you know i'm
never gonna do that again i'm gonna be
like the best husband i can be i'm gonna
be this and that the other
and it's like really sad because it's it
seemed like after a time he couldn't
like really control it
so may of 1966 uh
margaret who was his mom she actually
uh finally decided to divorce
ca the abusive dad now
um charles was like really excited about
this
and he actually drove all the way to
florida to help her out
so he's like would you move to austin
like be near us
and so he moves there he actually even
called the cops like he wanted the cops
like outside
the house like while his mom was getting
all her [ __ ] out of the house
so like in case his dad came back there
wouldn't be like a big [ __ ]
scene so he was aware enough to be like
okay i'm gonna help my mom get out of
the situation after all this time
so so they did that now so the mom moves
to austin
and um the youngest brother whose name
was john
also moved to austin so they moved like
closer to
charles the mom and the youngest brother
the middle brother actually
uh stayed in florida and worked for the
dad
ca like in his plumbing business now at
this point
um margaret who was charles's mom
she gets a job in a cafeteria she gets
her own place
um and her and charles remain very close
they talk to each other all the time
um also have a little bit i don't know
if i'd call it a stalker situation
but the dad ca be
calling up margaret all the time like
trying to get her to come back so like
calling her
like constantly calling charles
constantly
saying hey tell your mom to come back to
me i'm so lost without
her blahdy blah all of that kind of [ __ ]
so there was all that kind of situation
going on so obviously this is not a fun
time for anyone
uh involved and uh probably not
surprisingly
charles starts taking uh amphetamines
during this time period and also it was
during this time period
that he started having very very intense
headaches which like i said uh which
they found out later it's what that was
now again so we're in 1966 now
so the day before the famous
shootings uh charles goes to
he goes to a hardware store he buys some
binoculars
and a big knife then he goes to a
7-eleven
and buys some spam your favorite
he picks up his wife uh she was a
teacher but this was summertime
so she was actually she had a summer job
like working as a
phone operator i think it was for belle
and so he picks her up from work uh he
goes and has lunch with his mom
which was close to the college like
university of texas
then this is about uh this is july 31st
1966 like i said the day before the
shootings it's about four o'clock in the
afternoon
charles and his wife kathy they go by
and they visit some friends of theirs
uh they leave their friend's apartment
at about 5 50
p.m kathy goes to work she works from 6
to 10
in the summertime now he drops her off
at work presumably 45 minutes later
they think he started typing a suicide
note
now part of this suicide note says now
i'm not going to read all because he did
write a lot
but this is a portion of one of the of
the first suicide note that he wrote
they think
he says i do not quite understand what
it is that compels me to type this
letter
perhaps and this is before he had done
anything perhaps it is to leave some
vague reason
for the actions i have recently
performed i do not really understand
myself these days
i'm supposed to be an average reasonable
and intelligent young man
however lately i cannot recall when it
started i've been a victim of many
unusual and irrational thoughts
these thoughts constantly recur and it
requires a tremendous mental effort to
concentrate on useful and progressive
tasks yeah okay that's that's what i
remember
yeah yeah they telling you right there
yeah well he knows something's the
matter he knows some things matter
it's ideation the same thought going
over and over in your head that's that's
also from [ __ ] tbi
i get it sometimes we're just like the
same phrase will go over
it's usually just some random snippet of
a conversation from years ago
yeah that's what he's going through yeah
his shit's getting worse and worse and
worse and it's getting bigger and it's
[ __ ] his brain up
it's terrible yeah i mean like i said i
feel bad for i mean
obviously i feel bad for all the victims
because they didn't like they were just
innocent people walking around but this
guy's kind of innocent too
but he didn't i mean he couldn't help it
yeah it's not him
it's not him that's doing it yeah it's
like some [ __ ] in his [ __ ] brain
that's which is scary yeah because that
could happen to anybody yep
which is horrifying but you know i've
seen it happen to other people
yeah like when i was living in brazil
our uh our maid
was a little chick named ceta and she
had a brain tumor and she slowly just
kind of went crazy
but we couldn't help her you know over
there it cost too much money we didn't
have the money to help her
she ended up dying and you know knew
what it started out with
when she would iron our clothes because
she did all the laundry too
when she ironed the clothes normally she
put one crease down the front of the
front back of the pant leg right we
can't find him with two creases
where she would be a perfect two creases
weird you know what i mean one piece
next to the other which like i said it's
weird but it's nothing that you would be
you just be like huh that's what started
yeah started it a couple months later
she started [ __ ] cussing at us
in between stuff in between stuff
under her breath and [ __ ] like wow she's
being crazy you know what i mean
and then um she glitched out on my mom
and then
i can't remember what she did my mom
[ __ ] took her somewhere
she knew something was wrong it came
then she
came back with a note from the doctor
saying she had a brain tumor
that was some weird [ __ ] but we couldn't
help her the more i read about this case
and like the more i hear about show like
that the more i'm like freaking out
because
yeah i mean and she was uh
not even 30. well my uh
my uncle died of a brain tumor when he
was 32
32. remember that girl we used to party
at with [ __ ] pretty pretty ass blonde
one was going out a little shorter
[ __ ]
shirt yeah she had a brain tumor and
just died and she was what 29
29 you never know that she had one time
she was totally logical though it got
her all at once
yeah that seemed to happen like very
very it happened like in a couple weeks
really weird
it can't happen though because like i
said many years ago like my my uncle
died of
a brain tumor 32. i don't think he acted
super weird before the end like i never
heard anything about that but he was so
so young yeah
and it's just [ __ ] crazy
yeah esther said my uncle died of a
brain tumor at 45. i know it's like
[ __ ] sucks man
and there's like nothing you can do but
it's like nothing you can do yeah well a
lot of
most of them are inoperable yeah because
i mean in a weird place
yeah it's like when most of your brain
is like important it's not like oh we
can just scoop this part out and it's
not gonna like
have an effect holy crap i was watching
like i started watching on amazon prime
uh they have that series that's based on
lore you know the podcast
and they had one on their uh one episode
i was watching that was kind of all
about lobotomies and they were talking
about like trans orbital lobotomies
where they just like would stick the
thing like in your eye socket and then
like kind of scramble your brain a
little bit
and it was supposed to like cure
depression and all these other kind of
things and it's just talking about
all the after effects of all that
because obviously i mean the dude
wasn't even really a surgeon he wasn't
like qualified or anything
he just had the idea hey i'm going to
stick this thing in people's eye sockets
and sort of but he was a doctor i think
but i don't think he was like a
qualified surgeon and it's like you just
kind of stick it up in there just be
like yeah that's probably fine and go
like that and it's like that's not going
to be
that's not going to be good for anybody
yeah you're actually his [ __ ]
brother died of a [ __ ] brain tumor at
seven took about six months that's what
i mean it's like
it's you know and i know it's scary but
nature is indifferent yeah nature isn't
different it doesn't care
about you yeah uh well people are buying
into the corporate narrative of that
you're born you [ __ ] live a perfect
life
you get a job and [ __ ] you live out
you get a white
white house with a white picket fence
and there's a dog some people do get
that most people don't most people don't
though
most people don't though most of this
[ __ ] happens and it sucks because it's
like sometimes it's like some people
just like work their ass off their whole
life and never get anywhere
it's like and some people just have like
life [ __ ] on them at every opportunity
that you know [ __ ] they can't help and
it's just kind of like man what the [ __ ]
are you gonna do
well in other countries there's no
there's no upper mobility at all you're
just born
you're born in the gutter you [ __ ]
live in the gutter and dying together
but here's the thing you don't want to
get it's just like this is what this is
what schopenhauer's gonna say
don't get wound up in the sufferings of
the world they're gonna be there no
matter
if you know about them or not there's
all kinds of sufferings out there you're
not even aware of
all right and you know you don't feel
guilty for not knowing because you don't
know
all right again just be thankful for
what you have
yeah and like if you can help somebody
then help them but it's like you can't
save everybody you're just nature and
nature nature
has a way and nature's way is that
there's a lot of us
you know some of us die but it doesn't
matter other ones can continue on
i know you all die anyway i know yeah
but it's kind of like i
you know i like to think and i don't
want i don't want to be one of those
[ __ ] that's just kind of like
oh i don't give a [ __ ] because it's just
like oh millions of people die every day
because
i don't want you know i don't want to be
one of those people you can't be all emo
but you can't like you can't dwell on it
either you can't dwell on it either and
i'm definitely on the side of like
dwelling on it because i'm like oh man
don't don't dwell on it because you
gotta look at it this way
i can't do anything if you were a
scientist looking into a big ol
a big old [ __ ] glass vial of gnats
where [ __ ] millions of them are born
and die
over a period of about a year to you
it's just gnats coming and going
all right looking but to those gnats
there's their whole lives
all right but from your point of view
they just come and go well i think about
that sometimes
because i think about but sometimes i
think about that like when i'm walking
on the path or something
and like i'll see you know i'll see like
a dead squirrel
yeah or something it's all part of
system and i well and i think to myself
like how shitty that is and i'm just
kind of like oh well most people
wouldn't care i'm like well that
squirrel probably cared and i'm like
maybe you know what i mean
yeah but you gotta also look at it this
way
you're not even aware of all the people
that were born lived and died in rome
or in china and over the phone but i do
think about hundreds of thousands
well guess what how many people a
thousand years from now you will be one
of them
i just long for god and it won't even
[ __ ] matter yeah but i've i've
i've made peace with that [ __ ] i don't
care about that right
i just i care about i'm kind of
interested in like people that lived and
died that nobody like remembers like i
don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] if
anybody remembers me or not i don't give
a [ __ ] about that we won't be remembered
like i said i don't give a [ __ ] about we
would be lucky to be remembered for like
30 years 40 years 50 years after your
death i don't know why i don't give a
[ __ ] about that i just don't
i just don't the universe doesn't care
either that's what i'm saying
so don't worry i've made peace with that
fact but honestly i'm kind of interested
in people who
people like a long time ago that people
may have forgotten about i'm more
interested in that than i am about me
being remembered
a thousand years from now i don't care
about it anymore i had out-of-body
experiences and near-death experiences
you just become one with the force you
go into a [ __ ] parallel unit
another dimension and uh
life continues but you continue on in
another form
i think you're kind of recycled or you
go back to the [ __ ] cosmic
consciousness
you become one with a force and you
never come back um
either way i was under the impression
that once you go
in once you go into the cosmic
consciousness you never come back
you just become part of it i'm going to
be like a drop of water returning to the
ocean
i may be reincarnated as pookie yeah
and then when you're on that side of
reality you're outside the space-time
continuum
so you don't you don't care about the
past the present or the future too much
that's a singularity that's happening
away from you
so you don't feel like you lost anything
you're gaining
so i don't worry about it nothing to
worry about no i don't worry about that
well and like what xanada said the
thought of being dead isn't scary yeah i
agree
it's not scary to me you're not really
dead for me it's the thought of dying in
agony yeah that would suck a lot
that would suck that would go away
though i don't even you know what though
i don't even care about because
i know some people are like really
scared of like oh i'm going to die alone
or this or that
for some reason that doesn't bother me i
don't that doesn't scare me um
i'm not really scared of dying i don't
really want to like know that i'm dying
like i said i don't
when i think about like ways to die it's
like i would really rather not
like be in a plane that goes plummeting
to the earth and i'm just kind of like
and i know that i'm gonna die for like a
few seconds that would really blow
but i mean it'd be over quickly but i
would still would rather not have that
experience
right we already did a show on the
mandela effect
it was a long time long time ago it was
a long time ago
um other dimensions are annoying most of
the time
sure um but yeah i don't i don't know
just
the i don't know like the thought of
death doesn't really
it doesn't really alarm me all that much
like i said i don't really want to like
be in pain for a long time i don't want
to like [ __ ] but i'm not bothered
about
dying or i'm not bothered about being
alone or anything like that i don't know
i'm just not bothered by it
i'm not bothered about not being
remembered i just
honestly i kind of feel like i'm more
interested in like people like from
thousands of years i'm just
i i find that interesting i don't i
don't know if they would care
but i find it interesting like hey
here's this person that lived all this
time ago and like you can
you know it's sometimes an arc
archaeologist like if they come across
some house or something that's
underground it's like oh we found some
average person's house and here's all
their stuff
and like i think that's really neat
because i'm like wow you're like
almost like bringing that person back
from the dead a little bit because it's
like nobody remembered that person and
now everybody does so i think that's
kind of cool
but i don't really i don't particularly
care if anybody remembers spiritual
i don't know i guess is that bad and i'm
just kind of like
i don't know it just doesn't bother me
all that much
now that i'm i'm thinking about it it
doesn't bother me all that much
so another interesting thing that he
said in the same
letter um you know if you guys remember
what i just said
uh about the letter that he wrote
another interesting thing that he said
was that and this is he wrote this
before he did anything
okay he said that
like after he was dead he wanted there
excuse me to be an autopsy performed on
his remains because he thought that
there was something the matter with
him and he's like i'd really like to
know what's going on in there
um so can you please do an autopsy on my
remains after
i do what i'm gonna do so
basically he said hey can you like
[ __ ]
x-ray my head because he was talking
about like he had all these really bad
headaches so he knew something was the
matter
in this letter he also said that he had
decided that he was going to kill
his wife and his mom not because he
hated them
um but as far as his mom was concerned
he said in the letter he said i don't
think that she ever
enjoyed life as she is entitled to
um and he's tripping yeah well that's
what he said and he's just kind of like
and uh for his wife all he said was like
he
she's just the best person ever she's
the most wonderful wife ever
um he said but what i'm gonna do
um i want to spare them the
embarrassment
um i don't want them to suffer anymore
because he
he thought the world was like the worst
yeah and he was like i don't want them
to suffer
and i don't want them to be associated
with me
after i'm gone and be embarrassed and
suffer because of me he's [ __ ] true
so which i'm gonna say like i get that
he had a brain tumor okay
but i'm just gonna say because i know
that this is something that like a lot
of mass shooters
um have and they don't have a brain
tumor so they don't have a [ __ ]
excuse
they kind of like you know they'll take
a bunch of people out
and we've talked about this before yeah
they take a bunch of people out and then
take yourself out i'm like pro tip
how about you just take yourself out and
not like take all these other people out
with you didn't have [ __ ] to do
with any of your [ __ ] problems i've
already explained that would be really
nice i explained that
[ __ ] long couple years well i know
you explained it but i'm just saying
they don't they can't think that way
well clearly they can't think that way
all right first of all dude's got a
brain tumor he's he can't think clearly
but he cut he's kind of thinking along
the lines of those dudes that
i've lost my job i'm gonna lose the
house and lose everything
i have to kill my family to save them
the shame of my failure yeah that seems
a very comment like
with dude like dude mass killers that
seems like
yeah i'm just not like no it's fine it's
fine you just kill yourself you're fine
i'll just be over yeah that [ __ ]
in his mind it's almost kind of a
japanese thinking i lost my job i almost
killed myself
but you know but they're like i'm gonna
i've failed my family
i can't let them know that i failed and
i have to i have to save them the shame
of [ __ ] me being a failure and you
know then he kills the family
then when it comes time to turn the guns
on himself he's like i can't do it
oh well i'm just gonna go off and
[ __ ] make a new house yeah
you know that [ __ ] didn't that
did did not french dude do that
uh well there's been more than one
american dude that did that
was that john list he i think it was
back in the 70s or 60s that he did it
and then he eventually watered away got
another job
[ __ ] married and [ __ ] rebuilt a
whole new family
afterwards and then they eventually
caught him i think i think america's
mastermind
caught him being married to somebody for
20 years or something like that and then
you find out that before you met them
they had slaughtered their entire family
and then pushed out of killing
themselves and she was like ah never
mind i'm just going to like start over
i'll find some younger hotter wife we'll
have some kids
yeah it'll be fine what the [ __ ] dude
like i said if you really feel like
you're that much of a failure
just [ __ ] blow your own hat off i'm
just you know it's like don't take other
people with you nobody wants to go with
you okay
i'm just telling you that's right you
feel the suicide
it's like i'm not you know you do that
[ __ ] i'm not ashamed of you or anything
like that
the trip is that he was able to um
he did most of it through the six
through the 70s and 80s i think i think
i got caught in the 90s
maybe late 90s i told it was like i'm so
i'm so
he was able to make a whole new identity
for himself and [ __ ] well back then
it was much easier yeah that's the thing
i'm one of those people
like i said i'm not only not i would
never ever take anybody with me because
what the [ __ ] why would you do that
um i don't even want like and remember i
said like how
back in the victorian victorian area
remember like dudes that would like kill
themselves hey i'm going to jump in
front of a
train yeah and it's like dude somebody
has to clean up your splattered carcass
and it's like and you've traumatized
everybody on that train good job don't
[ __ ] do that
jesus yeah they were doing that [ __ ] in
america
so like self-absorbed it's so
self-absorbed they wanted the public to
see it
um it's grandstanding yeah and like no
one cares about your
[ __ ] dude it's just kind of like go do
it quietly
because that was uh they were doing that
stuff in
eastern seaboard of the united states a
lot of times
and like um in those days [ __ ]
guns were cheap and plentiful i mean you
could easily just shoot yourself
but see that wasn't showy enough back
then that's what i mean they can't just
do that
and spare everybody some [ __ ] agony
right no it had to be some big [ __ ]
thing in public
yeah and maybe
you know you're looking at it through
modern eyes it might have been kind of
like
almost a way of protesting pro you know
[ __ ] 1800 sucked okay it did but it
sucked for everybody
yeah but it might have been mental
illnesses kind of way of acting out
you know [ __ ] this [ __ ] up [ __ ] y'all
you know like i get that i get that
mindset
like i have that sometimes too but it's
like i would never in a million years
right it's just anger
you know you know y'all [ __ ] are
[ __ ] [ __ ] here comes the train
watch this
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you know i don't think
it's like that
well yeah it is but like i said it's
self-centeredness it's self-absorption
no one really cares that much about you
standing up standing up for yourself
also can be seen as [ __ ]
self-centeredness but
it's not really the same thing though
that's not really that you can't get
yourself in the mind of a dude from that
era
you have to know the all the details
yeah but dudes do it nowadays too
they might they're mad they're very mad
i get mad too pissed off
i don't go around like killing like
people that didn't have [ __ ] all to do
with it
like look at me [ __ ] that [ __ ] i don't
like attention whoring
and it just seems like a tension you're
trying to project sanity onto other
people
and that's where you get in trouble
you're trying to project
sanity and [ __ ] you're trying to
project [ __ ]
practicality and and reasonability into
other people it's just not there for
some people jenny
it's not no i know that yeah i mean
okay so esther is saying
uh i'm selfish i attempted and failed
trying to commit suicide the abuse was
too much for me but the thing about it
i don't think suicide in itself is
selfish at all
i don't think that's selfish at all the
only thing i think is selfish is trying
to take
innocent people with you that's all
honestly
um and i'm not saying that it's like uh
you know people should
commit suicide obviously but i'm just
saying that some people
the pain is too much and i get that um i
don't have any problem
with you know people just choosing to
hey i'm going to take myself out i don't
have a problem with that at all
the only thing that i think is selfish
if you is if you think oh i'm going to
take all these people out with me
because why the [ __ ] would you do that
my son is not thinking like uh when i
was living in boston
the woman that lived the woman who lived
across the hallway from me
her husband lived in there they were
both mental health professionals
she was taking care of all these
outpatients and [ __ ]
and she told me one of them was it was a
girl who [ __ ] she'd been through a
bunch of [ __ ] sexual abuse since she
was
little you know and um
one day she [ __ ] she was going to
kill herself
so she put a bunch of candles around the
[ __ ] bed
and went in there with [ __ ] 10
gallons of damn gasoline and poured it
all over the bed and said she got on the
bed and poured it on herself
and then just threw one of the candles
in the bed set herself on fire
burned herself up but she was in an
apartment
burned [ __ ] damn whole floor of the
apartment down
a couple other people died of smoke
inhalation
all right was she thinking of those
other people no
but chances are in the mental state that
she was in she wasn't even really aware
of those other people in the same way a
normal person would
yeah she was just so much into her own
little world she didn't realize that it
would [ __ ] put the other apartments
in jeopardy
so you know you just can't project
[ __ ]
rational reasonable thinking into
[ __ ] people especially in people who
are [ __ ] crazy
well yeah a lot of people are just
[ __ ] crazy and then a lot of them a
lot of the [ __ ] that shows up is memes
on the internet people [ __ ] jumping
on cars and jumping doing all kinds of
weird [ __ ] during these protests
a lot of them aren't me a lot of them
are just [ __ ] stupid if you went in
there i imagine some of those people got
[ __ ] iq of 65
definitely putting their life in danger
you know what i mean
i don't care what you believe in you
know what i mean [ __ ]
you throw yourself under the wheels of a
moving vehicle you're gonna get run over
just you know you point a gun at an
armed man he's gonna shoot you
yeah i was just i was i was seeing
something that oracle wrote about and
this is actually a really good way of
putting this uh the quote
my mother is important because she is my
mother and that's kind of what i feel
like
the dudes that do this kind of stuff
that go on these
rampages um and take their family
members out and then take a bunch of and
then
you know although he didn't kill himself
he ended up getting shot by police i
don't know if he was going he's not
normal to kill himself no
yeah that's not what i'm saying good um
she's saying no dude your mother is a
person who existed before you and she
has a life without you that's what i'm
saying
it's just kind of like i do kind of feel
like there is
they get so wrapped up they're real
myopic in their own
[ __ ] yeah it's self-absorption is what
it is you get so wrapped up in your own
stuff that everyone is just like
an extension of you an extension of you
you're an accessory of your
of your existence so like i know this
person so it's mine
yeah that's all i was saying that's all
i was saying that like if this like he
seemed self-aware enough
to know that you know there is something
wrong with me something is going on in
my brain that isn't right
um and i'm gonna do these things and
it's going to be embarrassing for my
family so he was that self-aware
uh he wasn't completely out of it but
the fact that
well i okay well i have to kill my mom
and my wife now because
that you know because they'll be
embarrassed and they're suffering
it's kind of like yeah but you didn't
ask them one
and two they have an entire existence
outside of you
um they're not just you know an
extension of your
psyche that's another person so i do
kind of feel like they don't
see other people they're so like
self-absorbed that they don't see
people other people as actual full
people you know what i'm saying
that really does seem like a lot of that
going on
and i see that a lot not just in this
dude who had a brain tumor like i said
i've seen it in other mass shooter type
situations like dudes that did this kind
of thing
well they're all did you have a brain
that's what i'm if you're a mass shooter
you're an outlier
well yeah you got a [ __ ] problem yeah
but i'm just saying that that's
like a pretty common thing of seeing
other people as like extensions of you
you're not gonna be dealing with a real
[ __ ] self-actualized individual you
know what i'm talking about
yeah so yeah so he's with the exception
of the [ __ ] guys that are on military
[ __ ] campaigns and [ __ ]
it's very that's a very different
situation
yeah it's just kind of like okay so
so he's saying that he's he's going to
kill both of them i think that he wrote
this before he had done it but he was
actually
planning to do that because he didn't
want them to be embarrassed quote
unquote by his actions
he didn't want them to suffer blah blah
blah so
august 1st a little bit after midnight
he goes to his mom's
apartment and stabs her
to death while she's sleeping
uh he put he puts her on the bed very
peacefully covers her up with sheets
and then he left a handwritten note next
to her body
and part of it said i have just taken my
mother's life
i am very upset over having done it
however i feel that if there is a heaven
she is definitely there now
i'm truly sorry let there be no doubt in
your mind that i loved this woman with
all my heart
so he just left her there like that
stabbed her in her sleep
because he didn't want her to wake up so
then he goes back to his house his wife
was
also sleeping and he stabbed her in the
heart three times
while she was sleeping so at least she
probably didn't know what hit her about
i'm sure she did it's [ __ ] hard it
takes a while to die from that
that's [ __ ] horrible so he's
[ __ ] crazy yeah i mean like i
said why the [ __ ] would you just
oh i don't know he's ending his he's
ending his world
and all the people that he needs yeah
but like i said that's like
that is some monstrous self-absorption
he doesn't think of it that way though
he's [ __ ] crazy
i don't know you're asking for for
rational reasonable behavior out of a
[ __ ] that has
has has a damn brain tumor but like i
said
he might not have had a [ __ ] great
disposition to begin with you know so
it's just
it's just a mixture well he had some
issues like even like before that
you know yeah like he had been like
abused horribly by
how many of these shows have we done
already on this show you know
[ __ ] do crazy [ __ ]
yeah and he's just this particular dude
this particular dude had damn brain
tumor he was the wrong man at the wrong
time for a brain tumor and this is what
happened
yep but there's a lot of this kind of
[ __ ] going on it just doesn't manifest
itself in this way
yeah but yeah so he stabs his wife while
she's sleeping
three times in the heart covers her up
with sheets same as he did with his mom
then he kind of wrote some more like uh
you know
the note that he'd been typing and then
he had a pen
and on the side of the note like in pen
he wrote
friends interrupted and then he wrote
the date
and then he said 3 a.m both dead
assuming that he met his mother and his
wife
now after that he wrote i imagine it
appears
that i brutally killed both of my loved
ones
i was only trying to do a quick thorough
job
if my life insurance policy is valid
please pay off my debts
donate the rest anonymously to a mental
health foundation
maybe research can prevent further
tragedies of this type
give our dog to my in-laws if you can
find in yourselves
to grant my last wish cremate me after
the autopsy because like i said he
wanted an autopsy because he knew
something was the matter with him
yeah he definitely wanted an autopsy of
like his brain
so then he um like i guess they were
renting the house that they lived in
so he left another note that said hey
there's here these two
rolls of camera film please develop
these and then he wrote like some notes
to his two brothers as well
and then he wrote like
there was he wrote on the outside of the
envelope that he put it in it was called
for like thoughts for the day that's
what he wrote on there
and then he put like a whole bunch of
like other like notes in there
and then on the outside of the envelope
he wrote the date which was august 1st
1966
then he wrote i never could quite make
it these thoughts are too much for me
so about quarter to six in the morning
on august 1st
charles calls his wife's work which i
said was bell system she was like a
telephone operator there over the summer
and he told her boss that she was sick
and wouldn't be coming to work that day
obviously because she was
dead you guys go ahead and hit that like
button please thank you yeah
hit the like grandpa says rolls of films
kids today don't know the struggle right
you got to like take it to the [ __ ]
well and you couldn't you didn't know
how the pictures were going to come out
until later so you'd go on vacation
you go on vacation and you take a bunch
of pictures and then you go to [ __ ]
walgreens or the one hour photo or
whatever and you get them back and
you'll be like ah [ __ ] me like none of
the like only
like one of good one came out rapper pov
said at least you didn't kill a dog
yeah you know what you know what shitty
i kind of thought that when i was like
reading about this too
yeah speaking of hey speaking to you
prepper i just got one of those lotion
or ocean [ __ ] um little ham
ham radios man [ __ ] that's coming
from china pitch cost me 200 [ __ ]
bucks
i'mma program that [ __ ] for all these
[ __ ] cool channels that they got here
in florida
they can't cut my internet off i'll have
you spent 300
on the [ __ ] race yeah yeah why did
you do that i wanted a [ __ ] cool
radio
[Laughter]
i wanted a cool radio that's my
emergency it's gonna be my emergency
radio for uh
storms and everything granthar's hammer
says when i was in college in the late
1980s i worked in a one-hour photo lab
people would bring in nasty homemade
porn all the time
i imagined that it was probably like 90
porn i mean that's what i always thought
like at the one hour photo
i always kind of thought every time i
took my boring ass pictures in there
like i always kind of thought they'd be
like
ah it's just like vacation pictures
lame grandpa's on him all right i got
you call sign ke
or ken
yeah so uh so yeah so
charles called his wife's work and said
she wasn't coming into work she was sick
also called his mom's work and told them
the same thing
obviously they were not coming to work
that day or ever again
which is horrible then
he wrote a few last journal entries um
you know which i don't really have any
uh thing of those
but later on that morning when the sun
came up
he went and ran rented a hand truck
uh he cashed 250 worth of bad checks
uh at a bank that's about 2 000 in
today's money
then he goes to a hardware store uh
at the hardware store he bought a 30
caliber
universal m1 carbine two additional
ammunition magazines eight boxes of
ammunition
and uh he told the cashier at the store
that he was hunting wild hogs
after that he goes to a gun shop
purchased
four more carbine magazines six
additional boxes of ammunition
can of gun cleaning solvent then he goes
to sears
at sears he was going on a [ __ ]
buying spree i had one of those
universal car beats
yeah yeah i had one for a while yeah
this piece [ __ ]
well that was a knockoff those those
were the those were the [ __ ] ar-15s
of the 60s and
of the 60s a lot of little [ __ ]
15 round magazines 20 round magazines 30
round magazines and stuff and just
a little 30 caliber carving rounds
they're fun to shoot but just
piece of [ __ ] springs wore out in them
yeah so yeah so then he goes to sears
and he buys a sears model 60 12-gauge
semi-automatic shotgun then he goes back
to his house
at his house he packs his foot locker
uh with a whole bunch of [ __ ] um more
firearms including a remington 706
millimeter bolt action hunting rifle
35 caliber pump rifle m1 carbine that he
had bought previously
nine millimeter luger uh smith and
weston
smith and wesson m19 357 magnum revolver
the shotgun he bought earlier a couple
other ones
uh the actually the shotgun he actually
saw the barrel off and the buttstock
uh he had about 700 rounds of ammunition
into this foot locker
he also packed uh some food including
the spam that he had bought at 7 11
earlier
some coffee some vitamins some dexadrine
uh excedrin for his headaches uh
presumably
some ear plugs a bunch of uh big jugs of
water
some matches lighter fluid some rope
binoculars a machete
three knives a transistor radio toilet
paper for some reason
uh a razor and a bottle of deodorant
yeah
so like i said he was planning on uh
going up there
that sounds crazy but that's what you
carry to the field well i know that but
i'm just saying that it's like
yeah he just has some training he's
gonna take he's gonna take toilet paper
and some [ __ ]
but the deodorant and the razor
that's something that your [ __ ] ncos
want you to carry because they want your
[ __ ]
freshly [ __ ] shorn all the time for
your camouflage paint
it's funny that he went up there he just
took that up there because of the habit
i kind of feel like yeah that was just
like a bunch of [ __ ] well and like i
said
you know his rampage it was a long time
obviously and he killed and wounded a
lot of people but
really it was only like an hour and a
half he planned to be up there for a
couple days
i kind of feel like he was like thinking
he was gonna stake it out up there and
he was just gonna like need all this
stuff
yeah like why would you like taking
snacks and [ __ ] like that he takes like
seven different firearms like
[ __ ] 700 rounds of ammunition he's
got like deodorant toilet paper come on
now
but yeah so like you said he wasn't
really thinking straight
so uh so he put some coveralls on over
his clothes
now he gets to the university of texas
at 11 25 a.m now he apparently had like
a fake id
uh that it was like a research assistant
identification so he had one of those
and he got a parking permit so he parks
on the campus
and he starts he had like a hand truck
so he was like wheeling all the
the foot locker uh toward the main
building
so he goes into the main building uh he
pushes the button for the elevator and
the elevator is not
working now at this point like this
woman that worked there named vera
palmer
uh came and said oh do you know i can
fix it and she came over and kind of did
something like got the elevator working
and at this point charles says to her
thank you ma'am
you don't know how happy that makes me
that's what he said to her like more
than once so he said that to her
so he takes the elevator up to the 27th
floor
uh which was i think the building was 28
floors so he goes up to the 27th floor
he takes the dolly um and the
with the equipment on it and he goes
like he gets out the elevator he goes up
one flight of stairs
and then he goes to this hallway and
then there was like another
uh flight of stairs that went to like
these other rooms that were up there and
there was like the observation deck
which is where he ended up
shooting from now when he got up to
this hallway that was where where he
encountered his first
victim who ended up dying
uh edna townsley she was a receptionist
she was 51
years old so he goes
uh up to her he knocks her down
with uh the rifle butt and then
split open the back of her skull
then uh taking the same uh you know the
butt of the rifle like busted her above
the
left eye and then he dragged her body
behind a sofa now these two other people
came in
named cheryl botts and don walden they
come into the reception area
for they were coming off the observation
deck now at this point like
don he sees uh charles has all these
guns
and didn't think anything about it he
just said oh well
are you just going up to the observation
deck you're going to shoot pigeons or
something
and charles is like yeah like hey how
you doing
and then like the two of them went down
in the elevator meanwhile he has just
killed a 51 year old woman and like
dragged her behind a couch so you know
there's that
so at this point uh the entrance from
the stairway he like blocked it like he
pushed a desk in front of it so like
people couldn't
come up there so then at this point
there's a dude named mj gabor his wife
mary frances
they have two sons named mike and mark
now they actually were in
town visiting mj's sister whose name was
marguerite lamport and she had a husband
named william lamport
and they just happened to be here that
day so around
quarter to noon they're coming up the
stairs from the 27th floor
and they find the desk that charles
whitman had put
into like across the entrance to the
reception area like to keep people from
coming in there
so mike and mark like kind of went
around the desk like what the hell
uh charles comes out and start shooting
at them
so uh shot mike in the shoulder and
shot mark in the head and then he
started shooting down the stairs
uh hitting marguerite and mary frances
mj and william who were farther down the
uh
the flight of stairs at that point were
actually not hit
uh they ran for help like they ran away
and
went to get help um charles whitman then
shot uh edna
who he had like [ __ ] he had like hit
her in the head with the
rifle butt he actually ended up shooting
her in the head
and then he went up to the uh
observation deck
now out of all of those people that he
met uh
mark who was mj gabor and mary france's
son one of their sons was killed he was
the one that was shot in the head
uh marguerite who was mj's sister
was also killed uh mike gabor
who was the dad he actually um
was injured he couldn't uh finish his
air force training he had to leave
because of the injuries
mary frances his wife uh was paralyzed
from the neck down
and left blind so you know there's that
uh claire wilson was the next
victim she was 18 years old a student at
the university of texas 11 48
a.m charles begins shooting from the
observation
deck this is about 230 feet above the
ground like i said 27
28 stories above the ground it's like
it's it's actually quite
tall if you see like pictures of it so
he just started randomly shooting people
uh around the campus and there was also
i guess like
by the side of the campus there was like
a street uh guadalupe guadalupe street
uh known as the drag there was like a
bunch of like kind of coffee shops and
bookstores and that kind of [ __ ]
he was also shooting uh toward in that
direction
so claire wilson who was 18 was the
first person that was shot
from the tower now her and a friend of
hers
thomas ekman they were leaving the
student union
and then uh claire wilson who was
actually eight months pregnant
was shot right in the belly
um they believe that charles whitman was
aiming
for her very obviously pregnant stomach
uh so she was shot
uh at 11 47 a.m the baby in her stomach
was
killed so
yeah not not fun so thomas ekman
uh went to help her and was shot in the
chest
and was killed instantly there was
another carbine right
yeah well he had like a bunch of guns
but i think that was like mainly the one
that they used yeah
so there was this uh woman that was
running by
named rita star pattern uh she actually
came by
and laid next to the pregnant woman uh
for an hour
like you know trying to keep her awake
and like trying to keep her from so
there was a lot of people that
really were kind of heroes this day
because even though there was still
actively
this because this dude like was shooting
for like an hour and a half
so they would actually come and like
either drag people out of danger or try
to help people or whatever even though
they were in danger of getting shot
themselves and indeed some of them did
but like i said some people were
actually like you know very brave
so this woman like i said who didn't
know her this
woman rita came by and just like
actually laid next to her for like an
hour kept her awake and like
try to keep her from passing out or
whatever now there was another guy that
came by named uh
james love and there was another guy
named john fox and
they were actually when the shooting
started they were like behind like a
barrier but they came out while the
shooting was still going on
and helped carry uh clear wilson to
safety uh and also pulled uh thomas
ekman's body out of the
way now claire got uh was as i said her
baby was killed because
uh charles whitman shot her right in the
stomach
uh but she was in the hospital for three
months but she did ultimately survive
the next guy that was killed was robert
boyer who was 33 he was actually a
mathematician he was like a
professor now he actually was just shot
in the lower back pretty much uh died
immediately
there was another guy named devereaux
maitland-huffman who was 31
he was shot in the arm and he actually
um at that point like he just kind of
fell to the ground and like pretended he
was dead which was probably like a
pretty smart thing to do
um now there was another a woman that
worked on campus
named charlotte uh dera shorey and she
actually ran again ran to their help to
help them
so they you know charles was shooting at
her but she like ran to help them
and she ended up uh trying to help them
and then she kind of went behind this
concrete flagpole
and uh ended up not getting shot luckily
hold on i got a question
what's that all right um who was it
xanada saying i didn't know 30 carbine
had that kind of range
30 carving is a [ __ ] weird ass
[ __ ] caliber
i used to hand load it because it was
almost impossible to find
during the time that i had it you
couldn't find it loaded you had to make
your own
um it was a 30 caliber bullet weight 110
grains
that left the muzzle at about 1900 feet
per second
it was weird it was it was the same
length as a 38 special
but it was a lot narrow it was 30
caliber instead
and it had a little automatic rim on the
back of it instead of a revolver rim
it was a weird cartridge i mean [ __ ] it
would have been a lot more efficient
just to put the thing in damn 30 miles
or 762 toe crev
been a lot shorter long skinny thing
which tend to make
jams it's just not a good shape and it
wasn't very tapered
which helped and it wasn't really great
at feeding
um the carbine itself
the adjustable sights versions you could
regulate it out to about 300 meters
but by the time that round got down
there there wouldn't be much left to it
of it
you know um a lot of the energy probably
spent be like getting hit with a 380.
it was made for up close you know
100 meters in closer mostly 50 meters
it was meant just to replace the 45
caliber pistol that's what it was
in this day i guess you would call it a
pdw a personal defense weapon
like a crank or like a
czechoslovakian scorpion
it's something better than a pistol it's
not a rifle
that was the concept but after world war
ii a lot of them hit the market
and you had a bunch of companies making
reproductions of them and selling them
because a lot of gis were used to that
and they would sell um
it wasn't ideal but they had an
aftermarket was kind of like the ar-15
of its time because you could get a 30
round mag or
15 round mags they had problems
you had to change those magazines out a
lot magazine springs went bad
the action springs [ __ ] they weren't
there was a little small
coil spring long it wore out you had to
keep
replacing spring packages on them to
keep them tip top shape
just wasn't really made that well
[ __ ] eugene stoner's ar-15 was being
made
and nobody believed in that it looked
like a damn ray gun as crazy as it
looked they never believed that that
[ __ ] would work it went to vietnam it
did pretty well
then it ended up being that's the one so
just it was the thinking of the time you
know
in those days i don't want to talk about
in those days the the m
the m14 would have been the go-to
[ __ ] weapon
but you know he saw that car being he
knew what it was so that's what he went
with
but that's that's a weird choice when
you from our point of view but that's
well like i said he had several others
but i do
i i feel like most people were probably
worse out with the with the carbine
yeah well the other ones that he had
from what i remembered if the movies
were accurate they were bolt action 762
rifles they were basically deer rifles
you know
with scopes i mean he had a sawed-off
shotgun he had like a bunch of other
[ __ ]
yeah he had a knife he had a luger he
had like yeah those are pistols though
yeah
yeah like i'm saying but he had like a
bunch of for long arms i remember he had
some bolt guns too
beowulf 18 says they talk about this guy
in the full metal jacket film yeah we
we mentioned that earlier and i said
that's actually a little bit erroneous
because i know
you know i know it was a joke but like
he did say that it's like oh he learned
to shoot and like the marines
i said he didn't technically because
like his dad taught him to shoot when he
was younger so he was actually like a
marksman before he went into the marines
but up in that tower that carbine would
have been
not the weapon to go for it you'd want
those bolt guns
and in most portrayals and reenactments
that i've seen when he was up in that
tower he was using it
what looked like a 308 or a 762 the same
thing
um right deer rifle
you know which that's that's what you'd
use for sniping that's what snipers
would
use remington model 70s
yeah or a winchester 700 glass bedded
barrels
if it's all match accurized it's done
well then you can reach out to 1100
meters
and hit a man-sized target reliably with
good ammo
and if you with a good optics if you
know what you're doing
really people you see all this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
about these these jack holes with these
assault rifles [ __ ] putting holes in
people
that ain't [ __ ] that's nothing
the right man with a bolt action rifle
in the right position is [ __ ]
is unstoppable snipers are [ __ ]
deadly deadly especially if they're
using them and it's not the weapon it's
the tactics
firing one shot and leaving and
vanishing then he fires the next day and
kills two and
vanishes and leaves then the next day he
kills two more and leaves
you never stay and fight
that's how it's done but it only takes a
certain kind of person to get that done
you know kosovo the snipers were working
the population over and they targeted
children first and women
because it put maximum terror on the
enemy
the idea is terror and horror it makes a
population just want to stay at home and
not go outside
and you can starve out an entire city
doing that ten guys can do it
okay good well don't give anyone any
idea well it takes teamwork
and and skill so if this is this is like
kind of shitty but
i guess i can understand how this would
happen yeah because
you have a guy a sniper that's up on the
28th
floor of a clock tower and he's like
just shooting at random people on the
ground
so at first like the first couple people
like
it's a big campus so no one really
knew what was going on um they just kind
of heard
sounds and some people thought oh there
was like construction going on nearby so
it's like they thought it was just from
that
or some people that even saw people like
falling
thought that it was just like uh like
maybe it was live
theater or maybe it was like an anti-war
protest because there was a lot of that
[ __ ] going on too on college campuses at
the time
so um even like
some people later that were like shot
and wounded and were laying there
they said that like some people walking
by were like hey get up
you know what i mean because they
thought it was fake which like i said
maybe you would
at that point but like i said that's
like uh yeah kind of shitty
but so at this point they kind of start
bringing like uh ambulances like armored
cars [ __ ] like that
so the next people to get shot it was
actually three people it was uh
david matson roland elky and tom herman
they were all in their early 20s they
were all peace corps volunteers
and they were actually walking to lunch
and uh david matson
he got a bullet in the wrist like it
blew part of his
wrist off um roland elke was hit in the
arm by shrapnel and then
uh he got shot in the leg when he
actually he had gone to like hide but
then he came back out
like to drag david matson back uh you
know
to where he was he would be safe and
then there was another guy like an older
guy homer kelly who was 64.
uh he was actually a shopkeeper in the
area he saw the three dudes get shot
from he came
out of his shop and tried to drag them
all in there and he was shot in the leg
uh well all of them were injured but all
of them survived
thomas yes crusoe played whitman in the
movie yeah we talked about that we
reviewed that movie i think
yeah uh somebody sent me somebody sent
me a copy of the movie on blu-ray it's a
great movie
it's a great movie it's made for tv yeah
it's called uh what was it called
uh something or other the deadly tower
deadly tower the deadly tower you could
talk
about this guy probably get it for a
couple bucks on on amazon it's it's a
good watch
it is a good thing and it's a real uh
young crustal doing it
and it's a real straightforward edit
it's almost kind of like an action-class
action slash disaster movie about this
dude
um and it's pretty accurate
to what happened yeah kressel nails it
but not only that one hit also the the
john carpenter
and crustal television show about elvis
the elvis special that one which doesn't
have anything to do with mass murderers
it's another crusade television movie
and carpenter directed it it's about
elvis that's also accurate really really
good
a forgotten made for tv movie you can
get it on you on you can stream it or
you can get it on
um dvd for a couple bucks it's good
yeah what was that called elvis
something or other this is called elvis
elvis yeah i'm pretty sure with uh kurt
russell yeah
it's worth it we have that as well but
yeah so
so yeah so there was another guy named
thomas ashton now he was actually going
to have lunch
with the first three guys like the peace
corps volunteers
uh and he was shot in the chest and died
immediately uh next we have
nancy harvey uh and ellen who was a
student and ellen
f gennady's i'm not sure if i'm
pronouncing that right uh who
worked there at the college they were
actually
again leaving together they were going
to lunch and they started hearing shots
they went back inside and then a guard
for whatever reason
said no no it's fine you can go back out
again
uh so they both went out back outside
like to whatever
they was they were doing and then uh
it apparently wasn't safe because nancy
harvey who like i said was a
student she was 21 she got shot in the
hip
and uh ellen was then struck in the left
leg
by the same shot like it ricocheted off
and like hit her in the leg
both of them survived they were injured
however
next up was alec hernandez who was 17
years old now he was actually delivering
newspapers on
his bike uh in the morning so he wasn't
a student or anything he was just
delivering newspapers in the
neighborhood
and he got shot in the leg also
uh next a girl named karen griffith who
was 17 she was a high school student
she was actually walking through the
area and got shot in the shoulder and
chest
and the bullet pierced her right lung
she lingered in the hospital for seven
days but unfortunately died
after that time thomas carr who was 24
was a student at the university of texas
he was actually hit in the spine
while coming to help karen griffith and
died an hour later
at this point there was a dude named
alan crum who was 40 years old he was a
retired air force
tailgunner and he was actually managing
one of the bookstores on campus so
he had actually seen alec hernandez the
you know the kid that was delivering
newspapers and got shot
he saw that happening so he ran out uh
and he thought it was a fight at first
he didn't really know what was going on
uh but he came out and he found out that
dude had been shot and he started
hearing shots
so he kind of took it upon himself to
start directing traffic like doing these
other things like trying to like get
control of the situation
um so he started doing that then he
couldn't get back to his store because
all kind of chaos was happening
so then he actually went to the tower
where they had figured out that charles
whitman was shooting from
and said that he would help the police
now
he actually i think he ended up getting
deputized because like i said he'd been
in the air force
and he was a tail gunner so the cops
were like okay fine we did all the
helping get i guess
so they kind of uh you know he kind of
started helping them out
so at this point there's another student
named david gunby who is 23.
um this is about five minutes before
noon he was actually
he had left the library and then he'd
forgotten a book so he was going back to
get it
and then a shot went through his upper
left
arm and went into his abdomen severing
his small intestine
and killing him pretty much instantly
uh then there was a couple brenda and
adrian littlefield
they had only been married nine days
they were actually coming out of the
tower uh brenda got shot in the hip
and then her husband like leaned over
her like look what happened and then he
got shot in the back
um at this point like an armored car
like i said they were sending in
ambulances and like armored cars to like
try to bring lag out the
injured people or whatever so they came
and
uh you know got the two of them out of
there so david gunby was killed
but the little fields uh were injured
but survived
interestingly uh or not
i'm not sure this is like kind of [ __ ]
up so david gunby who was actually like
i said
ended up dying when they were doing
surgery on him
uh because the bullet had gone into his
abdomen they found out
that this is actually a guy
he didn't die at the time but he died
like a long time later and they kind of
attributed to this
so it's like so he gets shot in the
abdomen
uh you know in his intestine right so
then they're doing the
surgery and then they found out that he
only had the
that he had only had one functioning
kidney to start with
like one of his kidneys was [ __ ] up
which he didn't know and
the kidney the only kidney that was had
been working had been shot
yeah hold on one second what sod asked
wasn't anybody shooting back
and people in the car as people in the
audience are saying yeah people were
shooting back
yeah if you if you watch the movie you
should you can stream it
deadly tower it's really good um
bystanders we're hearing about it was ha
people heard that it was going on
i think radio and television was telling
about yeah and people went down there
and people were going down there with
guns and shooting back up at him
some of them were people uh just who
happened to be there at the time
the thing was is that most people
weren't totally prepared the civilians
really weren't prepared for this
so they were shooting back with things
like 38 special revolvers
all right uh real common stuff that was
around
in the us at that time things like pump
action shotguns they just didn't have
the range and the accuracy you needed
to engage a guy up in a damn tower you
know you needed high-powered rifles i
mean you have to he was like
28. yeah but it's a very it's quite a
tall building
you need a high-powered rifle totally
zeroed in with great ammunition and a
really good marksman
and uh those are harder to find it's
gonna take time for
guys like that to arrive on the scene
and chances are
the first guys like that to arrive on
the scene would be
some kind of a police unit i don't think
this was in the modern era of
swat yet i think swat teams
actually were formed in a res in
response to such a sp
response to situations like this because
i don't think it was an actual swat team
that took this guy
or it was a prototype swat team no it
wasn't even i think it was just
like a couple of random like cops you
need
a special weapons and tactics team swat
you need a special response team for
guys because
women had training he was crazy as [ __ ]
but he had training
he knew that half the damn battle is
finding a great
fighting position a position to fight
from so
um that right there that's half of it
and then the other half of it was his
weapons selection he
he brought the right weapons what'd you
do bogey
regular policing isn't about that you
know
you so it was going to take specialists
to take care of this guy
with a mission i'm going to run a
commercial because i'm going to run to
the bathroom
she's asking to go out oh no put her a
little thing on her all right so we're
just going to do a commercial
and then oh you're leaving okay what
well i can't run a commercial if you're
leaving because you can't
okay well i will run the commercial when
you come back i'll let the cat out
okay good idea all right all right i
just cause like i said i like to do like
the [ __ ] for adam so i'm running a
commercial all right so we'll be right
back in just
a moment because i have to go to the
bathroom all right in 2019 the first
strange realities conference took place
in nashville tennessee
the pandemic in turmoil the following
year could not stop
2020's conference from thriving in
cyberspace as a live streaming event
now for 2021 the third annual strange
realities conference will combine these
worlds
into a paranormal hybrid event live in
person in nashville
and streaming online join us in
exploring just how truly strange our
reality can be
with an interdimensional lineup of
speakers presenting unique and
intellectual perspectives on magic
mysteries and the paranormal featuring
ellen greenfield dr j michael bennett
aka
dr future tim benall soraya
dr stephen finley aaron gulias amy
pachula
brent raines chris ernst heather mosher
michael hughes jose herrera joshua
cutchen kiki dombrowski
nathan isaac petey newman stephen snyder
aka recluse david metcalf timothy renner
steve stockton and fred
[Music]
it's gonna be amazing
[Music]
okay and i am back i just have pookie
here in the pilots in
the co-pilot seat for a minute i was
petting her but then she jumped down
here comes jenny let me go let poopy out
she's going come on
well put her little clothes on yeah yeah
she can't run around out there too long
because if we leave i'm not leaving her
outside obviously
but yeah so okay so where was i yeah so
this is like [ __ ] up
this is why i think at the time they
said that he'd killed like officially
this is [ __ ] up but the
15 people but actually they uh later
revised it to 16 because uh
david gunby actually didn't die at the
time as i said but because he'd been
shot at the abdomen and they discovered
that one of his kidneys the one that
hadn't been shot
was not functioning and he wasn't aware
of it
but the one that was shot was now [ __ ]
up
so he had to be on pretty much like
dialysis
for decades so he ended up
dying in 2001 from complications of that
so his death was actually ruled a
homicide
like much later because if he hadn't
been shot he probably would have been
fine
so like i said that's where the 16th uh
victim is coming from
but he didn't die until 2001. so
at this point so there's another guy
there's
uh and this is portrayed in the movie as
well because i remember the scene pretty
clearly
this is around noon uh you know when
this is like in the thick of the
shooting there's a police officer named
ray martinez now he was off duty but he
ended up hearing about the attack on the
news
he called the police station and they
said you know go to the campus and
direct traffic and he gets there like
there was some other
cops already doing that so he just like
went to the tower
and said okay well we're gonna try and
get in there and like get the dude
but he was surprised to find when he got
there there's basically a little like
only two or three other cops
and they were just like at the tower
going yeah we need to like get up there
and get that dude so like i said they
didn't have like a swat team or anything
like that
this was kind of a very much this wasn't
a situation i mean
happily this isn't a situation that
happens all that often
and back then probably even less often
so they weren't really prepared for this
kind of [ __ ]
so they didn't really seem to know what
to do
like so ray martinez gets there and he
gets up to the 27th floor and there's
basically only three other cops there
being like yeah we need to bust in here
but he's like going to shoot us he's
like
you know because he like uh they were
outgunned essentially
so at this point there's another 18 year
old uh
girl named claudia brunt uh and she had
a boyfriend named paul
sontag and they were
walking around the campus um they bumped
into their friend carlo wheeler
and then started hearing shots so they
jumped behind
like a concrete barricade like i said
there was some construction going on on
the campus or near
near the campus so they jumped behind
this concrete
but for some reason paul sontag
stood up uh looking for something or
anything
uh i don't know why and then charles
whitman shot him in the mouth
uh which killed him immediately uh
claudia rudd at this point
tried to run to him and then carla
her friend tried to you know tell her
not to do that
and while this was going on uh carla
wheeler got shot in the hand
and the same shot also struck claudia
rut
in the chest so
that's claudia was killed um you know
paul sontag was killed carla wheeler was
wounded in that situation the next one
was roy schmidt who was 29 years old he
was an electrician
uh again when he heard the shooting he
jumped behind his car
he was about 500 yards away from the
tower but the shooting went on for about
30 minutes and then
he thought that they were out of range
like that the
shooter would not be able to reach him
so he stood up
and pretty much as soon as he stood up
he got shot
in the abdomen so he was actually
um this is [ __ ] up but he was actually
the
one that was uh killed that was like the
farthest from the tower
for the fatality for others from the
tower was roy schmidt
that was uh 500 yards billy speed
24 uh he was a police officer
now this is about 1208 pm uh he was with
another
police officer and a few others they
were again hiding behind these concrete
uh you know this concrete barrier like
on the south mall
now he actually got shot through a gap
in the concrete uh he got taken to the
hospital but unfortunately
died at the hospital harry walchuk
38 who was a phd student he was actually
leaving a magazine store on guadalupe
street which was
you know kind of right next to the
campus and he got shot in the chest
and killed billy snowden 35
he was a basketball coach at the college
he thought he was out of range
uh but was just kind of like walking
along he got hit in the shoulder
while standing in the doorway of a
barber shop
he was actually the victim farthest from
the tower although happily he was not
killed he was just wounded
sandra wilson who was 21 also a student
she was shot in the chest on guadalupe
street but survived
abdul qasab 26 uh also a student he was
an exchange student from iraq
uh his fiancee janet paulos they were
both walking along near guadaloupe
street
uh were shot both were injured neither
of them died
lana phillips 21 also a student
she again thought she was out of range
but was shot in the shoulder
injured but didn't die oscar roy villa
21 also a student roy vela was walking
along with
irma garcia who was his girlfriend and
they got shot near the auditorium on
campus hog auditorium
uh they were injured but didn't die two
other students
jack stephens and jack pennington
actually dragged them out of the way
like drag them to safety
avelino esparza who was 26
was a carpenter he got shot in the left
arm near the shoulder
which shattered the bone his brother and
uncle dragged
him to safety and he survived robert
hurd 36 who was a reporter
uh he was also a marine he was shot in
the arm but survived
john allen 18 a student he was actually
looking at the tower
through a window of the student union
when a bullet struck the window
and a second shot severed an artery in
his right forearm
he was wounded but survived maurice
homan
a funeral director which is
[ __ ] up who was 30. he was actually uh
helping get people out of the uh range
of fire so he was using his ambulance uh
from the
uh from his business to take victims to
the hospital
and during the course of that activity
was shot in the right leg
uh on the corner of the thing and he
ended up uh
laying there for pretty much a long time
until somebody like came in and got him
but he
happily survived also uh fl
foster and robert freed they were
wounded in the crossfire
between charles whitman and people
shooting from the ground
which as i mentioned some people who
heard about it on the news like ran
there and uh you know started shooting
at the guy up in the tower so some
people were actually injured in the
crossfire
uh della and marina martinez who were
visiting for monterrey mexico
both wounded by bullet fragments
although they survived
dolores ortega who was 30 was also a
student
she got cut on the back of her head they
don't know if it was from a gunshot or
from flying glass from like you know
shrapnel type situation and then the
last victim was c.a stewart
was injured in the commotion he actually
they don't think that he was shot like
uh
but you know there was all this other
kind of [ __ ] going on and crazy [ __ ]
so like i said so the cops there wasn't
a swat team there wasn't any of that
like everybody this this unfolded over
more than an hour and a half so there
was ample time
for [ __ ] to come out on the news you
know people to show up
and like try to help out try to
contribute
but it really does seem like the police
force not
you know entirely of their fault i guess
because this kind of [ __ ] didn't happen
that often
they weren't really prepared for this
type of situation we got into this kind
of stuff in that la that hollywood
shooting remember
the two bank robbers the old school
hollywood the old school law enforcement
um brass their their top uh their top
guys
along with the politicians of the era
were
from another time these are kind of
world war ii and po
pre-world war ii people they
their idea of law enforcement was very
different from what reality was
they thought that you could walk around
with a damn club and a stick and a
little
38 caliber revolver and be able to
[ __ ]
keep people safe and [ __ ]
intimidate bad guys and take care of bad
guys
in a world where firearms like the
browning automatic rifle
the ar-15 ak-47s and the thompson
submachine gun were around
and then the m3 grease gun world war ii
changed [ __ ] weapons forever
the technology [ __ ] the the overton
window of what was acceptable for design
and
type of technology advanced you had to
update the police
and these are two examples that clearly
underlined that
police thinking was from another era
this one
and the hollywood shooting you have to
keep your police up to date
that's all yeah that's all it is they
have to [ __ ] be able to engage these
guys
they're not [ __ ] patrolling mayberry
these are
urban environments weapons technology
has advanced
and you can't control it you can make an
m3 grease gun in your [ __ ] house you
can make a looty submachine gun in your
house
with [ __ ] that you can buy from a
department store you can make ammunition
out of nail gun blanks there's all kinds
of weird [ __ ] you can do
the technolo now the 3d printing is
unstoppable
they got guys in europe with real strict
gun controls they have the
f gc [ __ ] gun control nine
which is a nine millimeter sub machine
gun you can make on a 3d printer it's
only got a couple of metal parts the
springs and the barrel
but uh you can make it all 3d printed
it's just cat's out of the bag
yeah i mean once everybody has 3d
printers yes cat's out of the bag it's
going to be
eventually they're going to be making
weird 3d printers for proteins and [ __ ]
like that they'll be able to
3d print a goddamn kidney in a house i
can make my own steak
good luck getting that in there what
happens if you just 3d print an entire
human body and then bring it to life and
it breathes a life
yeah you know the [ __ ] what happens
if you [ __ ] can just like
gene amplify or [ __ ] edit gene edit
out a [ __ ]
[ __ ] bio weapon at the house the the
cat is out of the bag
you know yeah i mean it's going to take
a while for like the laws to catch up
with that [ __ ]
i don't think they ever will well the
thing about it is that that always kind
of happens i mean technology is always
ahead of the law the law
you know moves very slowly because no
one really knows entirely like what all
the implications
of [ __ ] is going to be went back and
analyzed everything the driving force of
humanity is not government
it's technology governments don't free
you technology frees you in every
[ __ ]
in every case the good [ __ ] that
happened to human beings
wasn't because government did anything
it was because technology advanced
starting off with [ __ ] like the printing
press you know what i mean
the governments tend to want to stop
these technologies because it takes
power away from
them yeah eventually
eventually you're just going to deal
with people that don't need it's a state
or a government that they
there's real self-sufficient now i don't
think the government would want that
because you have robber barons that have
made entire fortunes on
you buying [ __ ] from them if you ever
get in a position where you don't need
them they're going to want to try to
stop that
but you got to look at it this way
whatever they're making money on now
that they're pissed off about that
you're not buying that's not going to be
there in a couple decades anyway
they used to have dudes that were
worried about whether or not you were
buying horse shoes or not
you don't buy horse shoes anymore making
horse shoes used to be a whole [ __ ]
job technology changes even the [ __ ]
jobs it changes all the robber barons
they can't stop it don't worry about it
do what you want to do
just don't get in trouble watch your own
back
victor says [ __ ] kidneys i want a t-rex
make a [ __ ] t-rex make a t-rex with a
big-ass dick
and let it go let's just see what
happens
you can tell i'm getting ready to go to
club yeah
are you are you really that drunk no i'm
not that drunk holy crap
hold on a second why i mean that's a
double i am too but
you know it's all right it's going to be
fun
yeah we'll see we'll see how it is it's
actually not really all that late i'm
just gonna like yeah
we're getting towards the end of the
show though we kind of did good yeah i
talked about all the victims that's good
so like i said um the cops are not super
prepared for this situation like i said
you can't really blame them that's
hadn't really happened in this area uh
to this extent
this is florida man [ __ ] everybody's
got that [ __ ] here
well a lot of people yeah um yeah
so we're okay where was i so yeah so the
comps are kind of trying to get closer
it's like it's kind of hard because he
keeps
you know laying down covering fire is
what he's doing from 20th floor and you
don't really know where he's gonna shoot
next
so but they they had like a little like
cadre of officers
and they uh started going toward the
tower likes us like some underground
maintenance tunnels and [ __ ] like that
um and again we mentioned this earlier
there were other police officers down
there that were shooting at him
and also like some other civilians that
were shooting at him so they were kind
of like trying to keep
uh the police officers trying to keep
them safe while
they were doing their thing so
basically uh they also had a
sharpshooter like a police sharpshooter
and he was in a plane and he was kind of
trying to go
like i i think he was more trying to i
don't think he was trying to hit whitman
necessarily but you know
like distract him you know what i mean
like from shooting at the civilians
uh so there was that kind of [ __ ] going
on too it's called engagement
yeah so at this point like there's three
cops uh
or two cops and one deputized air force
dude that they deputized that just came
there and wanted to help
so they go up to the 27th floor and at
this point they found
mike gabor from earlier who had been
shot um
he survived ultimately although he was
pretty [ __ ] up
they got him out of there and then they
go up to the observation deck
and uh so like i said he got deputized
so they go
to the reception area at which point
they found
marguerite lanport uh who was dead mark
gabor who was also dead
mary gabor who was uh essentially she
was blinded and
uh you know she was basically she can't
walk anymore
uh and mike gabor and mike kabor told
them hey
hey he's out there on the observation
deck so go out there and get him
so uh ray martinez gets out to the
observation deck first like i said they
they were actually this the movie was
like pretty accurate because i feel like
ray martinez was like a big character in
the movie
and so that was like a pretty accurate
uh
that that was a pretty accurate to what
actually happened so he gets down to the
observation deck
uh he told alan crum who was the guy
like i said the air force tail gunner
that they
deputized he's like hey you stay back
there so they go out to the observation
deck
um and at some point alan crum like
shot off his rifle like accidentally so
you know they're probably like why would
we dive ties to dude i don't know
so by this point it's about 1 24
in the afternoon charles whitman is
kind of like looking around for the next
target and then at this point
uh ray martinez and another uh cop whose
last name was
officer mccoy they come around the
corner and then they see him
and then martinez jumps out he shoots at
whitman but he missed
uh with his revolver and then mccoy
jumps out
uh while ray martinez was firing saw
charles whitman's head looking over
like the kind of thing and mccoy shot at
him
and hit charles whitman between the eyes
with a bunch of pellets killing him
instantly
uh but just to make sure got a double
tap
um he not only hit him in the head he
also kept shooting and like hit him in
the left side
and then at this point ray martinez took
the other officer officer mccoy's
shotgun uh
goes up to charles whitman's body and
basically shot him point blank with the
shotgun
like i said double tap they were making
sure the [ __ ] was dead
so they just basically just like shot
him
so there so there's that so the cops did
actually finally get up there
and they uh shot now
when they looked into cause like i said
when this was going on obviously it was
like a big chaotic situation but when
they
when the investigation began they didn't
really know
that charles whitman had also killed his
mom
and his wife prior to his rampage
uh they found that out later
uh you know after all of this had gone
down like they went to the mom's house
and they found her and then they went to
the wipes out that found her
so there was that whole situation then
as they looked into it farther
they noted that charles whitman had
actually gone to
as i mentioned earlier a bunch of
different uh physicians
on campus um and
complaining of uh headaches uh thinking
something was wrong irrational thoughts
things like that so he was actually
trying to get help for his
condition they had given him uh various
medications
uh you know he so he had seen like four
or five doctors
uh starting in 1965 like late 1965.
um he went to a psychiatrist uh the
psychiatrist didn't give him a
prescription uh but he got
from another doctor gave him some valium
uh so basically he goes to this other
psychiatrist named uh heatley dr heatley
and i guess like
um in his suicide note he actually
talked about this
doctor he said that he talked to him for
about two hours
and had tried to tell him that he had
felt overcome
with violent impulses
and they seem to i see i don't think
that they
necessarily took it as seriously as they
probably should have
like i said it's hindsight's 20 20
nobody knew that he was gonna do this
[ __ ]
okay but i do kind of feel like he did
try to get help he should actually
because he knew something was
wrong with him and he was very
frustrated because
i think he felt like they weren't really
helping him and he felt like he really
needed help and they weren't really
doing
anything about it maybe he didn't have
the money for an x-ray
maybe not although it doesn't seem like
he went to four or five different
doctors so he had money so it doesn't
really seem like he
had x-rayed his goddamn head you would
think and he was kind of
and he did know something was wrong with
his brain because he even said in his
suicide note like
you know autopsy my brain like after i
die because something's going on in
there
yeah he knew right so it's kind of like
it's that kind of thing
yeah so the psychiatrist
that he saw did note and this is part of
his notes
this massive muscular youth seemed to be
oozing
with hostility yeah that something
seemed to be happening to him and that
he didn't seem to be himself
that was like something that he just
felt like he was having these feelings
that were like alien
that's uh you know that's a symptom of
some head injury yeah
it says he readily admits having
overwhelming periods of hostility with a
very minimum of provocation
repeated inquiries attempting to analyze
his exact experiences were not too
successful with the exception of his
vivid reference
to thinking about going up on the tower
with a deer rifle and start shooting
people
so he did actually say ahead of time
because he was thinking about doing that
right like um you know less than a year
before he actually did it
so basically okay so he's trying he's
trying to help he's trying to get help
to get them to [ __ ] prevent it
yeah that's some [ __ ] which like i said
that's what makes this
like so [ __ ] tragic all around
because it's like it's not only tragic
because
of all the people who were killed and
wounded
but it's also tragic because he seemed
to know something was the matter and he
tried to get him out yeah didn't get him
and they didn't seem like they didn't
you know [ __ ] about this dude but that
was actually
that takes a lot of will in a way
heroism
to try to [ __ ] go to them and say
something's not right
help me i'm thinking about killing
people good check out my head
and they didn't do it i mean at least he
did that yeah i mean they didn't do it
well i i kind of feel like they didn't
i didn't realize i didn't know about
that part yeah
it wasn't on this dude it wasn't him
it was that it was that [ __ ] tumor
this is what this is what bums me out so
much about this case it was just scenic
seriously yeah well i feel like you
don't because
especially back then it's like they
weren't really versed
i mean i feel like nowadays that would
probably somebody came to you like now
they'd be like oh dude okay
we'll do something but back then i
couldn't grasp that
yeah i feel like it wasn't like a common
occurrence people didn't have like any
context for it so it's just kind of like
oh he just feels like this that's the
other but they didn't do
anything about it right they didn't do
anything about it
um you know and i can't entirely blame
them like i said they didn't have a lot
of
experience with this type of [ __ ] like i
said if you went to a psychiatrist
nowadays and said that
oh they would yeah they'd be like okay
we're gonna like pull this person out
because they know dude it looks right
into your head well yeah i'm alright
because we've had a lot of experience
with people doing this kind of [ __ ]
so but back then they didn't so it's
like i feel like they didn't really so
it was just like a tragedy like all
around
like every like everybody failed
yeah i i you know in in my mind i you
know i've heard this case before but
even back in the day i l i remembered
letting whitman off the hook
that it wasn't him that it was that it
was his [ __ ] medical condition that
did it
you know what i mean that wasn't the
real whitman
that's that was a brain tumor that could
do that it's like super sad
yeah so that's bad that he has to carry
this around
even in the afterlife you know talk
about his name is soiled by that
but he went for hell yeah to tell them
there's something wrong with it i mean
like i said that doesn't make like the
families of all the people that he
killed and wounded feel any better
because like if my you know relatives
loved ones were killed like that i
wouldn't feel anything
shouldn't go on him though but yeah he
tried to get help in a way
it's like i feel like no one almost no
one is to blame in this city it was
like a natural disaster yeah it just
seemed like
there was just so much [ __ ] that it's
like nobody has like 20 20 foresight
it's like nobody knew that he was going
to do this crazy [ __ ] nobody knew that
nobody did that the system didn't
understand it like i said i feel like
nowadays
if somebody came to a psychiatrist and
said that and you didn't stop him then
yeah
because now everybody knows they would
have given you a full [ __ ] checkup
yeah now everybody knows back then they
didn't they [ __ ] either operated on
you or kept you [ __ ] under [ __ ]
thorazine
and [ __ ] drug you up until you died
from that hemorrhage
because they can't operate on all of
them some of them just sorry man none we
can do you go die
yeah so if we cut in there we'd be
cutting out most of your brain
yeah you know it's looking so that's the
thing like he had been prescribed
medications
um he had dexadrine uh when he died that
was like in his foot locker
um now weirdly like they embalmed his
body like immediately but it's kind of
like this so they wanted to do
toxicology but
so it was like delayed so he ends up
getting because
remember like i said an even a suicide
note please do an autopsy because he
thought something was the matter with
him so finally
uh the day after the shooting they did
an autopsy
and uh they did find
a pecan sized brain tumor which we have
referred to earlier
um in his brain now
they're not entirely like at the time uh
the neuropathologist who did the autopsy
wasn't entirely sure if the brain tumor
could be if that was like the main thing
that caused the actions they said well
there's really no way of knowing
but as i said like later
you know neurologists or whatever like
disputed those findings it's like you
know
seeing the size of the tumor where it
was located
um that's probably like a big
indicator yeah of what was going on
there
grantus is in there [ __ ] bringing
he's in there
trying to re-explain it to some other
people you can't the government cannot
keep lists on 350 million people those
[ __ ] are too goddamn
incompetent
no super computer can do it they can put
a damn
laser beam on you and find out
everything about you
but they can't watch everybody at once
it's just
you're not civilians and people who
haven't worked for governments or never
work for companies that have contract
for governments
they have a very distorted and
unrealistic view of what the government
is
the government's a bunch of damn offices
filled with people that
are just trying to work day-to-day well
they're just doing jobs like everybody
else is doing
a lot of this [ __ ] we [ __ ] up sometimes
well a lot of that [ __ ] is not even a
real job a lot of it's busy work
um a lot of it is grifting and trying to
get some taxpayer money
um it's more like a gig than anything
else
even you go into these some of these
special operations units there's [ __ ]
problems
in in the thinking there just no
the larger an organization is
the less effective it is that's why they
subbed out all their important work to
[ __ ] civilian companies
private private militaries and private
intelligence organ if there was a james
bond he wouldn't be
in the government he wouldn't be a
government employee he would be a
contractor
he'd be in one of these security
companies
and you know he would be a civilian
doing that kind of stuff
on a government contract or uh
or you'd be doing it for a drug cartel
or something
and the drug cartel is actually owned by
a [ __ ] elected official in another
country
you know there's a lot of that [ __ ]
going on
but yeah so kind of what they thought
about
later like i said even though the first
neuropathologist
didn't necessarily think that that brain
tumor explained anything
but like later ones disputed those
findings and were like hey
maybe uh it was uh pushing against
uh charles whitman's amygdala which was
like
uh you know that's kind of like your
anxiety thing your fight-or-flight
kind of [ __ ] so like i said depending on
the part of the brain that it was in
it could absolutely um you know change
his personality and he really did seem
to be
sadly aware of what was going on so
this is kind of like i don't know for
some reason
this case bums me out maybe more than
the other ones because
we've talked about a lot of serial
killers and [ __ ] like that
but i feel like a lot of serial killers
as much as
maybe they had mental health issues
maybe
uh usually they had problems with
oh you didn't hear that [ __ ] rain
coming down yeah i heard the rain and
that pokey and pookie came running in
with a lizard in her mouth
of course she took the lizard out
[ __ ] through the lizard back out yeah
man she's always trying to like sneak
yeah she's always kind of like what
about you she's like look look what i
said give me that lizard i can put the
loser down
i brought him this is like thanks
you can't like bring them in here though
because they'll [ __ ] die
but um yeah so the sad thing about this
like i said we do a lot of shows about
serial killers and
as i said you know do serial killers
have mental health issues indeed a lot
of them do
do a lot of serial killers did they have
like horrible horrible shitty childhoods
yes a lot of them did
a lot of them had head injuries a lot of
them had things like that
so i do kind of but to a large extent
i feel like a lot of serial killers
still have enough
presence of mind if you want to call it
that to still be able to make a choice
yes they have a compulsion yes they have
you know
oh i feel like i have to do this or you
know an addiction if you want to call it
that
but they still have a choice where they
can like not do that
i don't know if that's the case
in this situation i don't i don't know i
i hate to say
i don't want to say definitively one way
or the other but i do kind of feel like
95
i do kind of feel like if this dude did
not have a brain tumor
i don't think this would have happened i
just don't think so
that was that's the thing that put him
over like you said
a lot of these serial killers have bad
[ __ ] backgrounds and this and that
and all these traits but there's a lot
of other dudes
trained
a lot of people did it's a culmination
of of all these bad traits and then
there's something like old [ __ ]
what's his name would say the x factor
there's [ __ ]
something in there that that some of
them [ __ ] spill over into becoming
serial killers and you just maybe it's
genetics just the
personality you know the way i think it
has to be both things and i've mentioned
this before
i really do think i don't know
if i don't know if
someone could be born that was just
completely normal in every way
didn't have any mental health issues
didn't have any genetic issues didn't
have anything
and they just had a really really shitty
childhood like abusive and everything
and then turned into a serial killer
i don't know if that's enough yeah
because like look at all the people that
had just like
[ __ ] horrific childhoods and they
turned
out all right like not all right they're
still [ __ ] up but they're not serial
killers
like some of them are like messed up you
know mentally and have
problems but they don't like hurt other
people so
i kind of feel like that's more that's
like the majority
so i think that it has to be i think
both
factors have to be present for that to
happen because like i said serial
killers thankfully
are very rare yeah and i think you have
to have both things
i don't think just one thing is gonna do
it because like i said even if you're
born with a proclivity toward being like
sociopathic or whatever
i don't even think that necessarily
makes you a serial killer unless other
factors are present if you were born
with sociopathic tendencies
but you grew up in a lovely like loving
household you had like a lot of loving
friends and stuff like that i think you
might still turn out okay
you still be a sociopath though well
you'd still be a sociopath
but you wouldn't kill people it's it's a
spectrum these are
spectrum [ __ ] disorders if you want
to call it that
yeah that's exactly what it is i mean
everything is on a spectrum
nothing is one or the other that's why
it's so complicated and that's why we
haven't been able to figure it out like
that's why i don't even think like
nature nurture that's not even a debate
it's like it's
it's a combination of both things and
you can't pride them apart
and you also can't predict what people
will do a lot of times people have
propensities to do things but it's
impossible to totally predict
because if you think you if you start
getting into situations like what
grafter said if you start getting a
situation where you think you can
predict it
[ __ ] will go out and try to pre
pre-crime you
like [ __ ] on on on down tom cruise
where they're arresting you and
convicting you of murders that you
haven't committed yet
they just think you're gonna just
because you thought about it because you
thought about it i think you're gonna do
it you know what i mean but you can't do
that either
you know well yeah because a lot of the
same guys that have that same profile
never do kill yeah and like i said you
see it all the time and that's why you
can't
just most of them are most of these
dudes are harmless that's another thing
yeah like that same personality type
that makes it due to serial killer
you're only seeing the ones that
actually do it there's a lot more of
them that never act well that yeah
that's what i was just gonna say you're
only seeing a very very very vanishingly
small sample like from a statistical
standpoint i bet you i bet you that's
two percent of them
so which means there's 98 percent of
them don't ever kill that don't ever
kill anybody
i mean they might be shitty people in
other ways yeah they're fantasizing
about it
but maybe draw pictures or something
yeah never do it or they
outgrow it they're like that for a
certain period and then they outgrow it
because even serial killers will outgrow
it some of them yeah
and sometimes it will it just depends on
because
[ __ ] man i knew like some teenagers yeah
that would talk about i'm gonna kill
this [ __ ] yeah and the other
thing but they never did it
right they they talked about it they
would like fantasize about it like who
hasn't done that yeah
i feel like most people have done that
kind of [ __ ] you just like you know
i've done it [ __ ] you're in a [ __ ]
somebody like annoys the [ __ ] out of you
one day and you're just kind of like
in line behind somebody at the grocery
store and you're like man i can i can
strangle this [ __ ] right now
you know what i mean because they're
like so [ __ ] annoying but it's like
you're not gonna do it
and like i feel like 99 of people would
not do it all right so
uh that's uh that's pretty much the end
of the show it was uh
went by pretty quickly i guess it was a
light day for super chats if you guys
want to send us any super chats now it's
the time to do it before we go ahead and
log off
you got anything else you want to talk
about jenny
i don't think so i actually got to the
end of the show yeah it's like
we had a pretty big crowd too nadine
says what about digging snuff films
uh no they have they have dudes that are
all into that but then they don't do it
themselves
yeah i kind of feel like the audience
for
even like extreme [ __ ] like snuff film
i'm not a snuff film fan obviously like
i love horror films i like watching fake
[ __ ]
film is a porn film where you kill
somebody that's what i mean it's like i
don't want to watch that for real
but i understand that some people like
to watch those i don't condone it
obviously but some people like watching
those but would never
hurt anybody you want to send your
present by the general uh
delivery orlando zip code contact jenny
off um
on facebook or instagram or something
like that should you give the
information
thank you no need thank you very much
for me too yeah
see you guys later you guys would have
fun making fun of elliot roger because i
want to do an elliot rodgers we should
do an elliot roger show because i will
just never stop banging on that [ __ ]
lame-ass pathetic
yeah [ __ ] yeah he's a trip
that dude there and his manifesto is
just
he had he had some issues that uh no you
think
yeah yeah he had a few a few little
issues
he was kind of robotic he's very robust
that was that was we ought to do a show
on that write that down i want to do the
other right
i'll put that in the next poll actually
because you know what though
it's those type of dudes i don't know
why
but it's like those type of dudes make
me madder than any other type of dude
oh i have a good one so i'm gonna get
like really really angry on that show so
i'm sure like everybody will be like
super into it
have a good one zoom out we talked about
this on the wednesday show but ever
since you've been like giving me
like ever since i've been on the
testosterone i'm kind of like yeah she's
more energetic
well i'm saltier she's salty [ __ ] well
i was always salty before i just kept it
to myself
now i don't oh here comes another one
thank you very much you victor do a show
on insults in general you can do that
oh you know what that you know what i i
i like that i like that idea but like i
said if you want to see
if you want to see me get like really
really really
really angry she gets all feminist with
these [ __ ]
you don't even want to see the feminist
rage coming out of this [ __ ] right here
you don't want to see it like a lot of a
lot of people make me mad but i'm able
to kind of like i'm just like man i'm
really mad right now but it's like it's
not worth it
right for some reason for some reason
prepper got it right bro
what would read what he said he was a
supreme gentleman
he's a supreme he did gentleman himself
that
i know i can't even i saw his little
video and everything
i can't even flirting with the camera
what's funny is that what are you
even thinking like what are you thinking
i don't i was looking at it
i was like dude man your problem is is
that you're actually gay you need to go
after the dude thank you jennifer
thank you very much ooh that's a good
one oh thank you very much
yeah thank you very much actually i was
looking at him i thought he might have
been sexually confused
well that could be if i just saw the
dude walking around i would think he was
gay
elliot rogers i mean
but the thing about it is that like look
it's the 21st century
if you're not a gay man a gay robot yeah
there's like a c3
it's a 21st century it's not like the
old like i understand like
back in the old days when back in the
shitty old days when you had like had to
like pretend you were something you were
not like all the time
you don't have to do that anymore it's
fine it's like yeah people are gonna
make fun of you but [ __ ] them it's like
you don't you're not going to get
arrested
you're not going to victor said the same
thing he says i thought he was gay too
yeah he gave he gave me gay vibes
but like i said it was not a gay man a
gay robot
he gave me the c-3po vibes you know what
i mean
he's how you doing hey
but he also but he also gave me the the
mentally ill vibes
well yeah like i said i think certain
schizophrenics still sometimes kind of
have that kind of robotics which like i
said
it's it's sad but it's kind of like in a
sense
i don't know like i said this is a
spectrum because i'm talking about
charles whitman and it's like i feel
a little bit bad for him because he had
a brain tumor and he seemed kind of
aware of it but not really
but at what point okay at one point does
your mental illness
yeah at what point does your mental
illness
get to a point like you still like have
a choice though
prepper says don't forget to include his
ass.com post where he was talking about
having a tiny dick and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that isn't included in his
manifest
i did not know the the the i did not
know the penis angle
i didn't understand the penis angle but
that that may have [ __ ]
yeah that might have been a contributing
factor yeah
that he was [ __ ] he was twisting
himself up into a knot about having a
little dick
him and d'angelo yeah yeah
they handled it kind of differently but
same kind of
same kind of attitude though i don't
like i kind of feel like it all comes
down to
the prep is going to be this angle yeah
okay victor says and cells are the worst
i agree
it all comes down to the problem with
all the like incels and
like even serial killers like the kind
of same attitude that they have
it's like this entitlement issue they
think they deserve things
no one deserves anything victor brings
up a good point he says but stuck up
guys always kind of seemed gay to me
i understand what you're talking about
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
i agree yeah i actually saw that in the
army
[ __ ] in my recon unit we had some
stuck up [ __ ] big ass
[ __ ] adonis [ __ ] scouts in there
and there was something
and it's one of them one of them he used
to [ __ ] with me so i'll [ __ ] with him
too
norman i remember you [ __ ] specialist
norman
no you came off as gay bro you came off
as [ __ ] as muscle gay to me
[ __ ] you ross funky wrong
you're like oh you're getting upset we
used to say that [ __ ] to each other too
though you know that's just the way the
army was you gay now you gay
well yeah because female is gay being
feminine
gay wars yeah he looked like a big old
woman
geriatric he was stuck up he was stuck
up and he
and yeah don't be stuck somehow somehow
even a big muscular [ __ ] who's
acting stuck up comes across as being
gay
a little bit yeah yeah i know you're
talking about garcia yeah it's true
yeah uh geriatric prank is saying i
don't even know what an incel is
it's a whole movement yeah somebody said
uh yeah no need for me too it's
involuntary it's this whole uh
what do you want is it a subculture yeah
okay look let me explain this
[Laughter]
they got dudes that don't they got dudes
that are not having any
success with women so they get on
because they're creepy weirdos
well let me let me let me finish what
i'm saying
hold your test okay
you have dudes that are not successful
with women so they get online
and they get in these forms and they
start talking to each other and they
start whipping each other up into a
[ __ ] frenzy
and then they do [ __ ] like [ __ ] trade
pictures and showing each other when
sometimes some of the [ __ ] was [ __ ]
hilarious this goes back to the 90s
back when they just did forms and you
know like on aol and [ __ ]
[ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious back then if
you want to know about old
old school internet culture go look at a
channel called wang
w-h-a-n-g and i think it has an
exclamation point
and he talks about all this kind of
stuff and individual guys
from those conversations well those
dudes
they were in ella they evolved over
[ __ ] what 20-something years
it's evolved into the in-cells of today
and it's a lot of factors the reason why
they're unsuccessful for women is one
they look like [ __ ] they look like [ __ ]
mostly because they sit around and
[ __ ] eat junk food and they live
sedentary lifestyles
and they don't take showers and they
have filthy [ __ ] rooms
um they're not really
suitable for [ __ ] dating okay their
whole thing is they think so that women
should be able to
accept them the way they are right but
they won't accept
women the way they are so you have these
they always want super hot chicks so you
have these dudes the
rock bottom of the dating pool and they
can't understand why they can't get a
supermodel
they're jerking off to all these [ __ ]
porn chicks hot porn checks and [ __ ]
online
and they're they're they're [ __ ]
sending money they're simping to all
these [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] cam girls and they can't
understand why that [ __ ] can't happen in
real life
it's [ __ ] that like me and grandpa's
came up in a high school back in
pre-internet where you had to [ __ ]
walk the walk and talk to talk it had to
be
face-to-face social skills
some of these guys they didn't cut most
of these new guys they did not come up
in that environment anymore
so they can't take face-to-face
rejection
so they can't approach and they don't
know how to engage well they can't take
rejection
at all at all and then they don't they
can't even work on themselves
you go dude you got to take a shower
dude you got to clean your [ __ ] room
dude you got to have a job
dude get a car dude [ __ ]
comb your [ __ ] hair like how do you
have a fashion session that's right
dude go [ __ ] do some [ __ ] dude be
something [ __ ] and
they don't even have that so it's just a
very very so
instead of [ __ ] admitting to
themselves that they haven't made
themselves into anything they blame the
women
yeah like for whatever reason hot women
won't hang out with me even though i
don't have a job or
all right it doesn't make sense and i'm
like ugly and don't shower
and you know what the [ __ ] but here's
the [ __ ] double standard
that same [ __ ] incel will be walking
around and he'll pass
a female bum laying there in the [ __ ]
gutter piss all over and [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that
she's got no teeth and she's going come
here boy come here and he's going no
no no no no she's like [ __ ] you and he's
like these men are all [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's that same
[ __ ] thing he is that woman
he's just doing it to to somebody else
you don't talk about
yeah it's the same difference the thing
that kills me particularly about elliott
right
if you're such a cool dude why aren't
you [ __ ] these bomb chicks
see well no well no no no you're a bum
well that's kind of the same level yeah
yeah
yeah that's what i mean it's just that's
what kills me about particularly
somebody like elliot roger who
wasn't a bum at least he seemed like he
showered and like dressed
like a model and had like a nice car and
[ __ ] so at least he had like the outer
trappings
of success if you want to call it that
he just didn't
he was so weird and creepy and entitled
that he thought that okay well if i
check off these boxes well i have a bmw
um i look okay i have this so hot women
should just like
throw themselves at me i'm like that's
one that's not how it works that's not
how women work i don't know if you don't
know that
but it's like so he was just expecting
oh i have all this
so why don't women just like come
flocking to me why should i have to do
anything
and then he would blame women for his
lack of impetus
i guess so it's all our fault even
though we don't even know he's alive
right yeah it's that just that's crazy
to me yeah well
that's crazy my take on elliot rodgers i
guess we're doing the l.a rogers show
now but no we're not we'll my take on
elliot rodgers
is that um physically he definitely had
what it
what it would take he wasn't bad looking
he was just like a normal life somebody
said well he have a dick
i don't that's there's guys that didn't
have a dick that's not a deal-breaker
it's really not most i think i don't
think i don't think most women really
care about that
well depends on who they are if the
woman if it's if it's a high-caliber
woman that could have it all now she's
going to go for the [ __ ] do with the
dick of course
because she's gonna go with the rich
dude the dick and got all the [ __ ]
jobs because she's
top tier woman she can get that but
there's a lot of other women that
[ __ ]
would have been within his range and
getting it's just that he probably felt
he was too
good for them yeah that's what i'm
saying entitlement and then
but i think a part of it was maybe lack
of experience
that and maybe something organic with
his with him
because he was very robotic he looked he
had the mannerisms of a person
that had mental illness so
uh his mental illness i think mostly
prevented him from [ __ ] having normal
relationships but he didn't really know
what it was so
he just he blew up yeah
he seemed to be on the autism spectrum
that's one thing he may have been and he
might have been slightly schizophrenic
but you know i'm not a [ __ ] doctor
but that's what he looked it looked
wrong i mean look at his mannerisms were
wrong yeah
if i was a girl i'd have something wrong
with this guy well like i said
you come across like that and yeah women
are going to stay the [ __ ] away from you
because they can sense that you're
there's something wrong with it that
there's something wrong with you and
it's like hey maybe this dude might kill
me
uh you know that's something we have to
look out for so
you know he might rape me he might kill
me you don't know he wasn't physically
imposing
no i'm no but that doesn't always matter
yeah that doesn't always matter it's a
because the thing is it's like this dude
could roofie me
at which point it doesn't matter if he's
physically bigger than me
it was on the spectrum yeah i'm sure
it's confirmed he got government
financial aid for it yeah okay
he did come across like that yeah he did
come across like that and i'm not saying
it's
because it's fairly rare for people on
the spectrum to be violent but
um he was one of the few i think yeah
but he did actually all right let's go
ahead and shut this down jim we got [ __ ]
we gotta do
yeah i gotta get ready we gotta we gotta
go out
yeah we decided we're gonna go out
tonight tomorrow night it's like we'll
get all our drinking out of the way in
one night
thank you thank you for those late super
chats people
for that for those that you have joined
the show late you can go ahead and just
wait a few minutes and the show will
reload up you can watch it from the
beginning it was a good show
i thought it came out good we got a lot
of information out we didn't get too
[ __ ] up
we didn't get too sidetracked yeah uh
because
like i said we knew we were gonna go out
afterwards at times and i'm gonna try
not to sidetrack too much because
you know uh but yeah so we will be back
on sunday probably be talking about
godzilla versus kong okay because we saw
that good movie
we just watched streaming streaming for
about seven bucks on uh
amazon was it was 5.99 or 279 5.99 i
think or 6.99
on amazon it's worth seeing it's fun
movie fun movie
just monster fighting monsters fighting
which like no no dialogue
i'm not mad at it it's the monster
fighting movie
good visuals but yeah all right so we
will see you guys
sunday afternoon so have a good weekend
up until then thank you everybody for
dropping by thanks for your super chats
we will see you guys on sunday
and bye